This episode is brought to you by Lloyds, which has been backing British ambition for over 250 years. Now, when you think about it, every dynasty in history has boiled down to two important elements, aspiration and action. And a classic example of this from British history, the rise of the House of Wessex, the family of Alfred the Great and his heirs, who between them established the United Kingdom of England. Yeah, it's a great story, isn't it, Tom? A great lesson in leadership, I think, for anybody. So Alfred and his heirs, they marry idealism and pragmatism.
本集由 Lloyds 赞助播出，该银行 250 多年来一直支持英国的雄心壮志。说真的，历史上的每一个王朝归根结底都离不开两个重要元素：抱负与行动。英国历史上一个经典的例子就是威塞克斯王朝的崛起，阿尔弗雷德大帝及其继承人的家族，他们共同缔造了英格兰联合王国。没错，这是一个很棒的故事，对吧，汤姆？我认为它对任何人来说都是关于领导力的一堂好课。所以，阿尔弗雷德和他的继承人们，他们将理想主义与实用主义完美结合。
They're brilliant at alliances. They're brilliant at managing power. They're brilliant of course at managing their money, which is a key part of political leadership. And of course, we are all reaping the rewards of their wisdom and foresight. When it's time to make your next move, you can bank on Lloyds to be ready. when you are. Because from new businesses to new homes and new life chapters, backed by generations
他们精于结盟，善于驾驭权力，当然也擅长理财，这是政治领导力的关键部分。当然，我们都在享受他们智慧与远见带来的丰硕成果。当您准备迈出下一步时，劳埃德银行随时准备为您提供坚实后盾。因为从新企业到新家园以及人生新篇章，在数代
of hope and ambition, you can see, Tom, why 14 million people trust Lloyds to help make their dreams a reality. Based on Lloyd's internal customer data from March 26. In Flanders Fields, the poppies blow, between the crosses, row on row that mark our place and in the sky the larks still bravely singing fly scarce heard amid the guns below we are the dead short days ago we lived felt dawn saw sunset glow loved and were loved and now we lie in Flanders fields take up our quarrel with the foe to you for from failing hands we throw the torch.
希望与雄心的支持下，汤姆，你可以理解为什么 1400 万人信任劳埃德银行，帮助他们将梦想变为现实。基于劳埃德 3 月 26 日的内部客户数据。在法兰德斯的土地上，虞美人花迎风盛开，在十字架之间，一排又一排，标志着我们的归宿，而在天空中，云雀仍然勇敢地歌鸣着在下方激战的枪声中隐约可闻。我们是死者，几天前我们还活着，感受过黎明，见过日落的余晖，爱过也被爱过，现在我们躺在法兰德斯的土地上。接过我们与敌人的争端，从我们无力的手中，我们抛出火炬。
Be yours to hold it high. If ye break faith with us who die, we shall not sleep, though poppies grow in Flanders fields. That's one of the most celebrated of all war poems, and it was written by a doctor, an army officer from Canada called John McCray, and he wrote it during the Second Battle of Ipe in May 1915.
愿你们把它高高举起。如果你对我们这些死者背叛了信念，我们将无法安眠，尽管虞美人花在法兰德斯的土地上盛开。这是所有战争诗中最著名的诗篇之一，它是由一位来自加拿大的医生、陆军军官约翰·麦克雷在 1915 年 5 月第二次伊普尔战役期间写下的。
And it is the poem that has affected enshrined the poppy as the symbol of the four million men who fell on the Western Front during the First World War. And Dominic, it's unusual among First World War poetry, isn't it? For actually, although it laments the deaths of the men in the war, it doesn't actually question the need for the war. It ends with this rousing appeal to the men who are going to be coming up to the trenches, presumably to be killed in their turn, to take up the torch to hold it high and to keep faith with those who are already dead amid the mud and barbed wire of Flanders Fields.
正是这首诗将虞美人花确立为第一次世界大战期间在西线阵亡的四百万男儿的象征。多米尼克，在第一次世界大战的诗歌中，这首诗很不寻常，对吧？因为它实际上虽然哀叹了战争中男儿的死亡，但并没有真正性质上质疑战争的必要性。它以对即将走上战壕的男人们的热血呼吁结束，他们大概会相继死去，去接过火炬，高高举起，并对那些已经死在法兰德斯土地的泥泞和铁丝网中的人保持信念。
Yeah, you're right. Hi, everybody. It seems unrepresentative of war poetry because we're used to war poems by Secreed Sassoon or Wilfred Owen that question the futility in the horror of the First World War. And those are the poems that people study in British schools when they're teenagers and they've become ever, of the war. But actually, in Flanders' fields, is probably more representative of what ordinary soldiers at the time thought. You know, we did a big series about the first few months of the First World War. We did an episode about the Christmas truce of 1914. And in those, we discussed how ordinary soldiers very rarely questioned whether they were doing the right thing. They believed, absolutely, I think, that they were fighting for principles of justice and they were fighting for their own national survival. And Dominic, even poets in the early months and years of the war,
是的，你说得对。大家好。这似乎并不符合人们对战争诗歌的刻板印象，因为我们习惯了西格弗里德·萨松或威尔弗雷德·欧文那些质疑第一次世界大战的残酷与徒劳的战争诗。这些诗是英国青少年在学校里学习的，并且已经成为了……其实，在法兰德斯的土地上，可能更能代表当时普通士兵的想法。你知道，我们做过一个关于第一次世界大战最初几个月的大型系列节目。我们做过一集关于 1914 年圣诞停战协定的节目。在这些节目中，我们讨论了普通士兵如何极少去质疑他们所做的事情是否正确。我认为，他们绝对相信他们是在为正义原则而战，他们是在为自己的国家生存而战。多米尼克，甚至在战争的头几个月和几年里，诗人们
were capable of celebrating the need for sacrifice. So the other famous poem that does this is Rupert Brooks, you know, talking about a corner of a field that is forever England, kind of lauding it. Yeah, exactly. And I think at the time, if you'd ask most of the Tom is, do you stand with kind of the Wilfred Owen, Seyfried Sosoon, anti-war school of poetry,
也有能力赞美牺牲的必要性。另一首著名的诗就是鲁珀特·布鲁克的诗，你知道的，他谈到了一片永远属于英国的田野角落，对其进行赞美。是的，完全正确。我想在当时，如果你问大多数汤姆，你是支持威尔弗雷德·欧文、西格弗里德·萨松的反战诗歌流派，
or do you stand with Rupert Brooke and John McCrae? They would say the latter, even though, of course, Seafrid-Sahoon and Wilfred-Oen fought very bravely themselves. We'll come back to McCrae's poem, and indeed the battle in which he wrote it, the second battle will be a little bit later. But first, let's set out what's coming in this series. So this series is about a single year in the First World War, the year 1915, and it's one of the most colourful, one of the most exciting years of the war.
还是支持鲁珀特·布鲁克和约翰·麦克雷？他们会选择后者，尽管西格弗里德·萨松和威尔弗雷德·欧文 themselves 本身也作战极其勇敢。我们稍后会回到麦克雷的诗，以及他写这首诗的那场战斗，即第二次战役。但首先，让我们列出本系列的内容。这个系列是关于第一次世界大战中的单个年份，即 1915 年，这是战争中最绚丽、最激动人心的年份之一。
If you think of the First World War as just sort of a muddy, miserable stalemate, you are dead wrong. There's all kinds of drama, and we'll be getting into this in this series. So we'll be talking about how Italy got into the war and how it prefigured the rise of fascism. We'll be talking about two of the war's most controversial and colorful stories. So that's the sinking of the ship, the Lusitania. So a Titanic-style story, except the differences in this case, the Lusitania is sunk by a U-boat, and this ignites this firestorm of controversy in America.
如果你认为第一次世界大战只是一种泥泞、悲惨的僵局，那就大错特错了。这里有各种各样的戏剧性事件，我们将在本系列中深入探讨。我们将讨论意大利是如何参战的，以及它是如何预示法西斯主义崛起的。我们将讨论这场战争中最具争议、最引人注目的两个故事。那就是卢西塔尼亚号客轮的沉没。这是一个泰坦尼克号式的故事，不同之处在于，在这个案例中，卢西塔尼亚号是被一艘 U 型潜水艇击沉的，这在美国引发了一场轩然大波。
And then in many ways an equally controversial story, which is the German execution of a nurse or spy, we will discuss which, called Edith Cavill in Brussels in 1915. And then we'll finish off with two episodes about one of the most dramatic military disasters in all modern history, which is the Allied attempt to seize the approaches to Constantinople. And Dominic, that's an episode that is kind of one of the great foundation myths, isn't it, of Australian and New Zealand identity in particular? Completely it is. So a little gift to our Anzaclessness there.
从许多方面来看，这是一个同样充满争议的故事，即德国人在 1915 年在布鲁塞尔处决了一名被称为护士或间谍（我们将讨论到底是哪一个）的女子，名叫埃迪特·卡维尔。然后我们将以两集节目结束，讲述现代历史上最戏剧性的军事灾难之一，即盟军试图夺取通往君士坦丁堡通道的行动。多米尼克，那是特别是澳大利亚和新西兰身份认同的伟大建国神话之一，对吧？完全是这样。所以这也是给我们尊贵的澳新军团精神的一点小礼物。
But today, I thought what we would do is we would kick off with the epicenter of the war, which is the Western Front. And specifically what we do is to talk about what it was like for ordinary soldiers told a lot often in their own words. So let's kick off with the, with outlining where we are, where we've got to. So at the beginning of 1915, the First World War has been going on for five months. And it began, as listeners will remember, with Austria-Hunger's decision to exact revenge on Serbia for the murder of Archduke Franz Ferdinand, who's now slightly been forgotten, I'm sad to say. And this triggered the European alliance system. So Germany piles in on behalf of Austria, Russia, France,
但今天，我想我们要做的是从战争的震中——西线开始切入。具体来说，我们要讨论普通士兵的真实生活，很多时候用他们自己的话来表达。因此，让我们从概述我们身处何地、我们走到了哪里开始。在 1915 年初，第一次世界大战已经进行了五个月。正如听众们所记得的那样，它始于奥匈帝国决定就谋杀大公弗朗茨·费迪南德一事对塞尔维亚进行报复，遗憾的是，现在他已经有点被人遗忘了。这触发了欧洲的同盟体系。因此，德国为了奥地利全力介入，俄罗斯、法国
and Britain are effectively defending Serbia. And from the very beginning of the war, the central powers, that's Austria, Hungary and Germany are massive underdogs because they have less than half of the total population of the Entente or the Allies as they become known. They've got half the military manpower, they've got far smaller economic resources. They can't win a long war. They know that. So what the Germans do is they gamble on knocking out the Western Allies in six weeks. They charge through Belgium into the heart of France. They're closing in on Paris at the end of August 1914, but they're driven back at the Battle of the Marne and they fool all the way back to the chalklands of the River Aine in eastern France. And there they literally dig in. And they dig the first line of
英国实际上是在保卫塞尔维亚。从战争一开始，同盟国（即奥匈帝国和德国）就在很大程度上处于劣势，因为他们的人口总数不到协约国（或后来被称为盟军）的一半。他们只有一半的军事兵力，经济资源也小得多。他们打不起一场长期战争。他们心知肚明。所以德国人孤注一掷，企图在六周内击溃西方盟友。他们穿过比利时挺进法国腹地。1914 年 8 月底，他们逼近巴黎，但在马恩河战役中被击退，并一路退回到法国东部埃纳河的白垩地区。在那里，他们真正地固守下来。他们挖了第一条
defensive trenches. By the end of 1914, beginning of 1915, these lines of trenches stretch all the way from the English Channel in the north, through Flanders, through Eastern France, to the Swiss border. That's about 450 miles. This is the Western Front. And very, very roughly, the British are guarding the bit in the north, so that's from the channel, down through Flanders to the French town of Amiens, and the French are handling everything to the south of that. And what they're basically trying to do is to push the Germans even further back, so out of France and out of Belgium. But this is a military challenge,
防御战壕。到 1914 年底、1915 年初，这些战壕线从北部的英吉利海峡出发，穿过法兰德斯、法国东部，一直延伸到瑞士边境。大约有 450 英里长。这就是西线。非常非常粗略地说，英国人守卫着北部的部分，也就是从海峡穿过法兰德斯到法国小镇亚眠，而法国人则负责南部的一切。他们基本上在试图把德国人推得更远，也就是把他们赶出法国和比利时。但这是一项军事挑战，
the like of which has never been seen in history, because it's very difficult to push people back when they have machine guns, trenches and barbed wire, which give the defenders a massive advantage. So basically, if you attack, you end up. up dying. That's the issue. And there had kind of been hints of the challenge that the allies might face in doing this, haven't there? In the American Civil War first, and then the war fought between the Russians and the Japanese in the early 20th century. And there was the occasional
是历史上从未见过的，因为当敌人拥有机枪、战壕和铁丝网时，想把他们击退非常困难，这赋予了防御者巨大的优势。所以基本上，如果你发起进攻，你最终就会送命。这就是问题所在。盟军在这样做时可能面临的挑战其实已经有了苗头，不是吗？首先是在美国南北战争中，然后在 20 世纪初俄国人和日本人之间的战争中。偶尔也会有
military strategist who would kind of write a book about this and say, an industrial war is going to be horrific. But by and large, military strategists, the top brass in the various armies of the competence in the First World War, before the outbreak of the war, had not thought that that was going to be an issue. They had thought that it was going to be a kind of massively mobile combat. And so really, no plans have been drawn up with how to deal with this eventuality. Not at all. And actually the story of the next four years is them actually figuring out that they were wrong. So, as we'll see, when we will come in the next episode to one of many extravagantly mustachio generals who has written a sort of little pamphlet about offensive doctrine,
军事战略家写一本书来谈论这一点，并说工业化战争将是可怕的。但总体而言，在第一次世界大战爆发前，各参战国军队的军事战略家和高层并没有认为这是一回事。他们曾认为这将是一场高度机动的战斗。所以真的没有为如何应对这种可能性做好任何计划。完全没有。事实上，接下来四年的故事就是他们实际上发现自己错了。因此，正如我们将看到的，当我们在下一集里遇到众多夸张八字胡的将军之一时，他写了一本关于进攻教条的小册子，
about how you win wars through dash and vigor and charging forwards, which is General Kodona, the Italian Supreme Commander. I mean, this is very common. And actually, the story of the First World War is these guys realizing they were completely utterly wrong. And that basically they're going to have to figure out a way to break the enemy defenses. And in experimenting, they will kill hundreds of thousands of their own men. I mean, this is the sort of tragedy of it.
关于如何通过猛冲猛打和向前冲锋来赢得战争，也就是意大利最高指挥官卡多纳将军。我的意思是，这非常普遍。事实上，第一次世界大战的故事就是这些家伙意识到他们完全、彻底错了。基本上他们必须想办法打破敌人的防线。在不断试验的过程中，他们将杀害数十万自己的人民。我的意思是，这就是这类悲剧所在。
And it's why they're cast as kind of the donkeys leading lions and all that. But to be fair to them, I mean, it is a massive, massive. problem without an obvious answer. I mean, they're not killing hundreds of thousands of people just for the fun of it. None of them know what to do. Exactly. So we, I think we alluded in a previous series, Lord Kitchener, great British kind of war hero, here of the Boer War and whatnot. Great mustache. Great mustache. He goes to see the trenches at the end of 1914. He says, this is not war as I understand it. You know, this is something different. I do not know how you break this barbed wire and machine guns and stuff. Anyway, what was it actually like then to live in the trenches?
这也是为什么他们被描绘成率领狮群的驴子等等。但公平地说，我的意思是，这是一个巨大、巨大的问题，却没有一个显而易见的答案。我的意思是，他们杀死几十万人并不是为了好玩。他们谁也不知道该怎么做。没错。所以我想我们在之前的系列中提到过，基甸纳勋爵，伟大的英国战争英雄，布尔战争及其他战争的英雄。蓄着漂亮的大胡子。蓄着漂亮的大胡子。他在 1914 年底去查看战壕。他说，这不是我所理解的战争。你知道，这是完全不同的东西。我不知道如何打破这道铁丝网和机枪之类的东西。无论如何，当时住在战壕里究竟是什么感觉？
1915. What did it look and feel like? We know more about this than any previous war. We're very fortunate because so many of the survivors told their stories to things like the Imperial War Museums or History Archive and there were a series of brilliant literary memoirs. And one of the most celebrated of all those literary memoirs, quite rightly, is Robert Graves' book, Goodbye to All That. So Robert Graves, very well known, of course, I. Claudius. So great kind of classical scholar. Some quite outlandish ideas. I think about classical mythology, Tom. Yeah, he was a big fan of the mother goddess.
1915 年。它看起来和感觉起来是怎样的？我们对这场战争的了解比以往任何一场战争都要多。我们非常幸运，因为太多的幸存者向帝国战争博物馆或历史档案馆讲述了他们的故事，并且还有一系列精彩的文学回忆录。所有这些文学回忆录中最著名的其中之一，也是理所当然的，就是罗伯特·格雷夫斯的书《告别这一切》。罗伯特·格雷夫斯，当然非常知名，《我，克劳迪斯》。这是一位伟大的古典学者。有一些相当离奇的想法。我想是关于古典神话的，汤姆。是的，他是大地之母的忠实粉丝。
But his memoir, goodbye to all that, is a fantastic, fantastic window into the experience of the war. So to give you a sense of Robert Graves, he was born into a fairly wealthy Anglo-Irish family in 1895. He went to Charterhouse, one of the great public schools. And Domney, didn't he have a German name? Kind of a bit like the royal family. I don't know if he changed it. He did. His name was Robert von Ranka Graves.
但他的回忆录《告别这一切》是一扇极好、极好的窗户，让我们得以窥见战争的经历。为了让你对罗伯特·格雷夫斯有一个概念，他于 1895 年出生于一个相当富裕的英爱家庭。他曾就读于查特豪斯公学，这是一所伟大的公立学校。多米尼克，他不是有一个德国名字吗？有点像王室。我不知道他有没有改掉。他确实改了。他的名字叫罗伯特·冯·兰克·格雷夫斯。
But he dropped the von Ranker. He kept quiet about that. He did keep quiet about it. So he's a very accomplished person, Robert Graves. He wrote poetry. He boxed at a very high level. He was a great classical scholar. He won an exhibition to Oxford.
但他去掉了“冯·兰克”。他对此秘而不宣。他确实对此秘而不宣。所以罗伯特·格雷夫斯是一个非常有才华的人。他写诗。他以很高的水平打过拳击。他是一位伟大的古典学者。他赢得了去牛津大学的奖学金。
And then just 11 days into the war, he is commissioned as a junior officer in the Royal Welsh Fusiliers. So he's very patriotic. He wants to join up. And he's finally sent to the front in May 1915. And I thought it would be interesting to make the journey with him, as it were. So his war narrative opens, with him arriving by boat at La Ave in France with six other young officers in the Welsh
然后，就在战争爆发仅仅 11 天后，他被委任为皇家威尔士团的见习军官。所以他非常爱国。他想参战。他最终于 1915 年 5 月被派往西线。我想和他在某种程度上一起踏上这段旅程会很有趣。因此，他的战争叙事以他和威尔士团的其他六名年轻军官一起乘船抵达法国勒阿弗尔开篇，
fusiliers. And his first memory, he says, as soon as we'd arrived, we were accosted by numerous little boys pimping for their sisters. I take you to my sister. She very nice. Very good. Jigger Jig. Not much money.
他回忆说，刚一到那儿，我们就遭到了一群拉皮条的外国小男孩的纠缠，他们为自己的姐姐拉客。我带你去我姐姐那里。她很好。非常好。吉格·吉格（意指性交易）。钱不多。
Very cheap. Very good. I take you now. Plenty champagne for me. I mean, he didn't go to Charter House to do that kind of thing. Not at all. Well, we don't know because he doesn't explicitly say that he didn't take up on their offer. But he implies that he didn't because they were too busy.
非常便宜。非常好。我现在就带你去。有很多香槟等着我。我的意思是，他去查特豪斯可不是为了做这种事。完全不是。嗯，我们不知道，因为他并没有明确说他没有接受他们的提议。但他暗示他没有，因为他们太忙了。
Well, this is the man who wrote I Claudius, I suppose, so maybe he did. So he and his fellows are told they're going to be attached, not to their own regiment, but to a different regiment, the Welsh regiment, and they've got to head up the line with their men. And Robert Graves, he's not yet 20 years old, so he's 19. And he is told, this is going to be your platoon of 40 men. Now, the vast majority of these men are working class. So this is your classic example of kind of cross-class collaboration in the trenches. They did not go to Charter House. And as he says in his book,
好吧，这就是写下《我，克劳迪斯》的人，我猜他也许真的去了。因此，他和他的伙伴们被告知，他们将被分配到的不是他们自己的团，而是另一个团——威尔士团，他们必须带着部下前往前线。罗伯特·格雷夫斯当时还不到 20 岁，也就是 19 岁。他被告知，这将是你的排，有 40 人。现在，这些士兵绝大多数是工人阶级。所以这是战壕中跨阶层合作的典型例子。他们没有去过查特豪斯公学。正如他在书中所说，
many of them are either wildly too old or too young. So he says, Fred Prosser, a painter in civil life, who admitted to 48, was really 56. David Davis, a collier, a minor, who admitted to 42, and Thomas Clark, another collier who admitted to 45, were only one or two years junior to Prosser.
他们当中有许多人要么年纪大大超龄，要么年纪太小。所以他说，弗雷德·普罗瑟，平民职业是一名油漆工，自称 48 岁，实际是 56 岁。大卫·戴维斯，一名煤矿工人，自称 42 岁，而托马斯·克拉克，另一名自称 45 岁的煤矿工人，只比普罗瑟小一两岁。
And the oldest of these men is a guy called James Burford, is another minor. Burford gives himself away because he's confused by the safety catch on his rifle. He says, what's this? And then he says to Graves, you know, I haven't fired a rifle since 1882. And Grave said, didn't you fight in the Burr War? And he says, no, I tried to re-enlist, but they told me I was too old, sir.
这些人当中年纪最大的是一个叫詹姆斯·伯福德的人，也是一名矿工。伯福德露出了马脚，因为他被步枪上的保险栓搞糊涂了。他说，这是什么？然后他对格雷夫斯说，你知道的，我自 1882 年以来就没开过枪了。格雷夫斯说，你没有参加过布尔战争吗？他说，没有，我曾试图重新入伍，但他们告诉我我太老了，长官。
That was 14 years ago. I had been an old soldier when I was in Egypt. My real age is 63. So he's like Corporal Jones in Dad's Army. Exactly he is, yeah, with his experience in Africa. But then five of them are too young. So you're meant to be 18, but over the course of the war, about a quarter of a million younger boys lied about their age to fight in the British Army.
那是 14 年前的事了。我在埃及的时候就已经是一名老兵了。我的实际年龄是 63 岁。所以他就像《爸爸的军队》里的琼斯下士一样。完全是的，凭借他在非洲的经验。但其中有五个人太年轻了。所以你本来应该年满 18 岁，但在战争期间，大约有二十五万名更小的男孩隐瞒年龄去英国军队参战。
And five of these guys are in Graves at Spatoon. One of them is only 15. And he keeps, like the classic teenager, he keeps falling asleep on duty. Oh, leave me alone. Which is a kind of capital offence, but Graves always, you know, excuses it or whatever. So teenage lion. Exactly. So they're loaded onto this troop train bound for the front.
其中有五个人在格雷夫斯的排里。其中一人年仅 15 岁。他一直像典型的青少年一样，在值勤时不断睡着。哦，别管我。这算是一种重罪，但格雷夫斯总是，你知道的，原谅他什么的。所以是个十几岁的狮子。正是如此。于是他们被装上这辆开往前线的运兵列车。
And they're heading to Betune, which is the railhead, which is the end of the line. And that's near France's northeastern border just south of Calais. And it takes them 25 hours on this train. Very boring. They play cards to pass the time. And they finally arrive. It's 9 o'clock at night. They are, and I quote, hungry, cold and dirty.
他们正前往贝蒂讷，那是铁路终点站，也就是线路的尽头。那是法国东北部靠近加来以南的地方。他们在火车上度过了 25 个小时。非常无聊。他们打牌来打发时间。他们终于到达了。当时是晚上 9 点。他们，引述原文，又饥、又冷、又脏。
And on the platform, the guy who's going to guide them to the front is waiting for them. A little man, says Robert Graves, in filthy khaki. He's going to take them on foot to the trenches, which are about six miles away. We marched through the unlit suburbs of the town. We were all intensely excited at the noise and flashes of the guns in the distance, says Graves. I mean, that's an amazing phrase, isn't it? Intensely excited. So at this point in Graves' career, and perhaps more generally in the parabola of public reactions to the war, it's still seen as exciting.
在站台上，那个将带他们去前线的人正在等着他们。罗伯特·格雷夫斯形容，那是一个穿着肮脏卡其服的小个子男人。他将带着他们步行去大约六英里外的战役战壕。我们穿过了镇上没有灯光的郊区。格雷夫斯说，我们所有人都对远处的枪声和炮火闪光感到无比兴奋。我的意思是，这是一个惊人的词组，对吧？无比兴奋。所以在格雷夫斯职业生涯的这个阶段，或许更普遍地在公众对战争反应的抛物线上，它仍然被视为一件令人兴奋的事。
Of course. I mean, it would be exciting, would it not? to go to war for the first time, you're 20 years old, or in the case of James Burford, you're 63. Maybe you're speaking for yourself there. Well, don't forget, they're going voluntarily. These are not people who are being conscripted. These are people who have chosen who have elected to go to do their bit.
当然。我的意思是，这会很令人兴奋，不是吗？第一次去打仗，你才20岁，或者像詹姆斯·伯福德那样，你已经63岁了。也许你是在为自己说话吧。好吧，别忘了，他们是自愿去的。这些人不是被强征入伍的。这些人是自愿选择去尽自己一份力的人。
Yeah, I guess that's true. They are nervous, though. Gray's notes that they're singing hymns to keep their spirits up. The Welsh always sang when they were a bit frightened and pretending they were not. It kept them steady, he says. We marched towards the flashes and we could soon see the flare lights curving over the trenches in the distance. The noise of the guns grew louder and louder. Then we were among the batteries. So this is the kind of artillery batteries.
是的，我想这是真的。不过他们很紧张。格雷斯注意到他们在唱圣经赞美诗来振奋精神。韦尔斯人总是在有点害怕又假装不害怕时唱歌。他说，这让他们保持稳定。我们朝着闪光的地方行进，不久就能看到照明弹在远处的战壕上空画出弧线。枪声越来越大。然后我们在炮兵阵地之间了。所以这是那种火炮阵地。
At this point, they see their first kind of enemy action, as it were. A German shell flies towards them and it lands 20 yards away. And as it explodes, they all throw themselves to the ground. There's an explosion. And then they hear this kind of tinkling, which is the sound of the little bits of shell casing, falling down, buzzing down all around, as Grave says. And one of the sergeants says Riley, they calls them the musical instruments. And they all get up and they trudge on and they get to a village called Combrain, which is about a mile from the trenches now. And here they're led into this ruined house, which had previously been a chemist's shop. And here, you know, there are people waiting. They give them their gas masks, their respirators. They give them their field
此时，他们看到了可以说是他们的第一次敌方行动。一颗德国炮弹朝他们飞来，落在20码外。随着它爆炸，所有人都扑倒在地上。一声巨响。然后他们听到这种叮当声，那是小块炮弹壳落在地上、四处嗡嗡作响的声音，正如格雷夫斯所说。其中一个中士说雷利，他们管这叫乐器。然后他们都站起来，艰难地前行，来到了一个叫孔布兰的村庄，现在离战壕大约有一英里。在这里，他们被带进一栋破损的房子里，这里以前是一家药店。这里，你知道的，有人在等他们。他们发给他们防毒面具、呼吸器。他们发给他们野战
dressing, so the kind of bandages and stuff. And they are given a little bit of something to eat. So bread, bacon, rum and bitter stewed tea sickly with sugar. And then once they finish that, the guide leads them on again. It's still very dark, by the way. They're led into these woods east of the village, and they go through the woods, and then they see an opening, and this is the beginning of the trench network. And they go down into this long, deep trench, which has been cut in the kind of clay of the soil, and Graves gets his torch out as they're walking to see what it's like.
包扎用品，比如各种绷带之类的。他们还分到了一点吃的。有面包、培根、朗姆酒和苦涩的炖茶，甜得令人恶心。吃完之后，向导又带着他们往前走。顺便说一句，天还是很黑。他们被带进村子东边的树林里，穿过树林，然后他们看到了一个缺口，这就是战壕网的起点。他们顺着这条又长又深的战壕走下去，战壕是在土壤的粘土中挖出来的，格雷夫斯一边走一边拿出他的手电筒看看是什么样子的。
and he realizes to his switch switches it off almost straight away because he realizes to his horror that they are walking on live field mice and frogs that have sort of carpet of them they've all fallen into the trench
并且他几乎立刻意识到——他马上把手电筒关掉了——因为他惊恐地发现，他们踩在活的田野老鼠和青蛙上，那些小动物铺成了一层地毯，它们全都掉进了战壕里
and couldn't get out again and I guess you can tell from that that this is still the early stages of the war because you still have wildlife in the trench system and you have trees so you know by 1916 1917 that that wood
并且爬不出来。我想你可以从中看出，这仍然是战争的早期阶段，因为战壕系统里还有野生动物，还有树木，所以你知道到1916年、1917年，那片树林
will have just become shattered tree stump yes exactly so by now I mean, he's pretty tired. They've been on the road a long time. He's carrying, they're all carrying these heavy kit bags and they've hung everything else on their belts. He's got on his belt,
就会变成残破的树桩。是的，完全如此。所以到现在，我的意思是，他相当累了。他们在路上走了很长时间。他背着，他们都背着沉重的装备包，把其他所有东西都挂在腰带上。他的腰带上有，
revolver, field glasses, compass, whiskey flask, wire cutters, periscope and a lot more. He's struck by how wet and how slippery the trench is. They can hear the hiss of rifle bullets coming at them. And actually somebody says to him at what point, there's no point in ducking if you hear a bullet.
左轮手枪、野战望远镜、指南针、威士忌酒瓶、铁丝剪、潜望镜以及更多东西。战壕又湿又滑，给他留下了深刻的印象。他们能听到步枪子弹呼啸着向他们飞来。实际上，有人在某个时候对他说，如果你听到子弹声，就没有必要躲避。
Because if you can hear a bullet, because if you can hear the bullet, it means it's gone by you. So it will kill you before you hear it. So if you hear it, no point. You know, you're fine. Anyway, they trudged down this trench and they get to a dugout and that is the battalion headquarters where the colonel is waiting for them. And Graves is surprised how cozy it is. So they duck in and it's that classic scene that you've seen. So for our British listeners, you'd have seen it in Blackadder goes forth, the comedy series. It's quite cozy. There's like a nice ornamental lamp. There's a table with a tablecloth. The, uh, The people inside are having their dinner or whatever.
因为如果你能听到子弹，因为如果你能听到子弹，就意味着它已经从你身边飞过了。所以它在你听到之前就会杀死你。所以如果你听到了，那就没必要躲了。你知道的，你很安全。无论如何，他们艰难地走过这条战壕，来到了一个掩体，那是上校正在等待他们的营指挥所。格雷夫斯对这里如此舒适感到惊讶。所以他们钻了进去，那就是你见过的那个经典场景。所以对我们的英国听众来说，你会在喜剧系列《黑爵士第四季》中看到它。它相当舒适。有一个漂亮的装饰灯。有一张带桌布的桌子。呃，
They're eating off polished silver. There's a gramophone playing records. There are easy chairs. So the colonel, his senior offices, are having their dinner. Could I ask a really dumb question? Yeah. Where are they getting the electricity from? Is it a wind-up gramophone?
里面的人正在吃晚餐什么的。他们在用擦得发亮的银器吃饭。一台留声机在播放唱片。有安乐椅。所以上校和他的高级军官们正在吃晚饭。我能问一个真的很蠢的问题吗？可以。他们的电是从哪里来的？是个手摇留声机吗？
I might be a wind-up, yeah. I don't actually know it occurred to me when I said there was a gramophone. So the adjutant says to Graves, right, you and your platoon are going off to Sea Company under Captain Dunn. And good news for you, he's the soundest man in the battalion. Top shows. So, tremendous. Off they go again into the trench network. It's now raining and it's very muddy, still very dark.
可能是手摇的吧。其实我也不知道，当我刚说有一台留声机时我才想到这一点。所以副官对格雷夫斯说，好啦，你和你的排将去邓恩上尉手下的C连。对你来说是个好消息，他是营里最靠谱的人。太棒了。好极了。于是他们再次出发进入战壕网。现在正在下雨，非常泥泞，天依然很黑。
They see their first casualty. They pass a stretcher party and they're carrying a man who's got a sandbag over his face. And the guide says, oh, who's that? And one of the stretcher bearers says, it's Sergeant Gallagher. He thought he saw a fritz in no man's land near our wire. Sergeant Gallagher, it turns out, fired a percussion bomb at this shape. but Sergeant Gallagher aimed a little bit too low the bomb hit the top of the parapet
他们看到了第一个伤亡人员。他们经过一个担架队，抬着一个脸上盖着沙袋的人。向导问，哦，那是谁？其中一个抬担架的人说，是加拉格尔中士。他以为他在我们铁丝网附近的无人区看到一个德国佬。原来，加拉格尔中士向这个黑影发射了一颗震击炸弹，
it bounced back and had exploded in his face No, that's the kind of thing I'd do And the stretcher bearer says Riley Poor silly bugger It's not worth sweating to get him back He's put paid to whatever And indeed it turns out that Sergeant Gallagher dies What an awful way to go
但加拉格尔中士瞄得稍微低了一点，炸弹击中了胸墙顶部，
Terrible wound, yeah Must have, I mean there must have been so many people Thousands upon thousands who died in similar ways Anyway, at last they reach their company, sea company, and the dugout that belongs to Captain Dunn. So this is, Robert Graves says, it's a two-room timber-built shelter in the side of a trench. It's a very similar scene. There's another table with a tablecloth. There's a bookcase.
它反弹回来并在他脸上爆炸了。不，这就是我会做的那种事。担架员说，雷利，这个可怜的傻瓜。不值得为把他弄回来而费汗水。他已经完蛋了，不管怎样。果不其然，加拉格尔中士死了。多么悲惨的死法啊
There's whiskey bottles and whatnot. And Captain Dunn is waiting for them. So he's Graves' superior officer. And Graves is astonished to find that Captain Dunn is actually two months young. younger than he is. That is to say Captain Dunn is himself only 19. And Captain Dunn is your absolute classic public school jolly, breezy, um, officer. Hugh Laurie in Blackadder. See, he be paid by Hugh Laurie. His opening words to Graves are, well, what's the news from England? Oh, sorry, first I missed introduce you. This is Walker, clever chap, comes from Cambridge,
可怕的伤亡，是的。一定有，我的意思是当时一定有那么多的人。成千上万的人以类似的方式死去。总之，他们终于到达了他们的连队，C连，以及属于邓恩上尉的掩体。罗伯特·格雷夫斯说，这是一个位于战壕侧面的两室木结构掩体。这是一个非常相似的场景。有另一张带桌布的桌子。有一个书架。
fancies himself as an athlete. This is Price, who only joined us yesterday, but we like him. He brought damn good whiskey with him. Well, how long is this war going to last and who's winning? We don't know a thing out here. So he's a bit like asking the score in the test match or something. Exactly. And Graves says, well, this is the news from England. And then Dunn says, okay, well, let me tell you what's like out here in the trenches. Dunn has this tremendous line. He says, we have absolutely nothing to do with the French, except when there's a battle on. And then we generally let each other down. Well, we've seen that was true, haven't we, from the series we did on the opening months of the war. And Dunn says this is basically how it's going to work.
有威士忌酒瓶之类。邓恩上尉在等他们。所以他是格雷夫斯的上级军官。格雷夫斯惊讶地发现邓恩上尉其实比他还要年轻两个月。也就是说邓恩上尉自己也只有19岁。邓恩上尉是你绝对标准的公学那种快乐、轻快、呃，军官。就像《黑爵士》里的休·劳瑞。看，他简直就是休·劳瑞扮演的。他对格雷夫斯说的第一句话是，那么，英国有什么新鲜事？哦，抱歉，首先我忘了介绍你。这是沃克，聪明的小伙子，来自剑桥，
breakfast at 8 a.m. Then we clean the trenches and we inspect and we check our rifles. We work all morning. And what he means by work, he says, in the majority of our time here, we work on the trench. We dig, we reinforce the parapet. We, you know, try to get rid of some of the vermin. We do all this kind of thing. Then at 12, we have lunch. We work again from one till six. So they're basically like a kind of group of navvies or something. And then we have, then the men feed again. We have stand two at dusk for about an hour. We work all. night and then we stand to for an hour before dawn and that's the general program sounds fun it's not the end of the world right i mean it's better than being in the coal mine right well as we would discuss so graves gets a little bit of sleep and then at 1 a m done wakes them up and he says i'll give you a tour so they have a look over the parapet very gingerly and graves gets his first glimpse of no man's land it's dark and he can hardly see anything but little later when it's lighter he gets a periscope and has a look. And he can see that the German trenches, that's marked by a line of sandbags, they're just 400 yards away. And although he doesn't really say this in his memoir, this must be
自诩为运动员。这是普莱斯，昨天才加入我们，但我们很喜欢他。他带来了该死的上好的威士忌。好吧，这场战争还要持续多久，谁在赢？我们在前线什么都不知道。所以这有点像在问测试赛的比分什么的。完全正确。格雷夫斯说，好吧，这就是来自英国的消息。然后邓恩说，好吧，让我告诉你前线的战壕是什么样的。邓恩有一句绝妙的台词。他说，除了有战斗的时候，我们和法国人没有任何关系。然后我们通常会互相拖后腿。好吧，正如我们在关于战争头几个月的系列节目中所看到的，这确实是真的。邓恩说，这基本上就是未来的运作方式。
a spine-tingling moment. After all this journey, after all these months of waiting, you finally see the enemy line. It's just 400 yards. You know, you could walk to it within minutes, although you'd get shot. And the no man's land as yet is not kind of churned up mud, is it? There are still flowers to be seen. No, he says a flat meadow. with cornflowers and whatnot, long grass, a few shell holes, there's a wreck of an aeroplane, and he can see barbed wire, theirs and ours, but that's it. He has another little doze, and he listens to the men grumbling about their lice, a big issue for them, we'll come back to this, and then they have breakfast back in the dugout, bacon and eggs, coffee, toast and
早上8点吃早餐。然后我们清理战壕，检查并擦拭我们的步枪。我们整个上午都在工作。他所说的工作是指，我们在大部分时间里都在战壕上工作。我们挖土，加固胸墙。我们，你知道的，试图摆除一些害虫。我们做所有这些类似的事情。然后到12点，我们吃午饭。我们从1点到6点继续工作。所以他们基本上就像是一群筑路工什么的。然后我们，接着士兵们再次进食。我们在黄昏时分进行约一小时的“警戒”（Stand Two）。我们通宵工作，然后在黎明前进行一小时的“警戒”，这就是总体计划。听起来很有趣。这并非世界末日，对吧？我的意思是，总比在煤矿里强吧？好吧，正如我们所讨论的，格雷夫斯睡了一小会儿，然后在凌晨1点，邓恩叫醒了他，说：“我带你参观一下”。于是他们非常小心翼翼地探头越过胸墙，格雷夫斯第一次瞥见了无人区。天很黑，他几乎什么也看不见，但过了一会儿天亮一点时，他拿了一个潜望镜看了看。他可以看到德国战壕，那是用一排沙袋标记出来的，距离只有400 yards。虽然他在回忆录里没有真正提到这一点，但这一定是一个
marmalade, so not bad, and just as they're getting stuck in, Dunn's manservant, his batman, his man called Kingdom, rushes in, his eyes blank with hot. horror and excitement and he says gas, sir, gas, they're using gas. And Dunn says the most British thing that anybody's ever said. He says, very well, Kingdom, bring me my respirator from the other room and another pot of marmalade. Can you, can you eat marmalade while you're wearing a gas mask? I think marmalade sure is the priority, no? You'd smear it all over your tube, wouldn't you? If you want to find out what happened next, I think the thing to do is to read the book, because I don't want to do the whole book. But I thought we'd
令人毛骨悚然的时刻。经历了这段旅程，经历了数月的等待，你终于看到了敌人的防线。只有400码远。你知道，你几分钟内就能走到那里，虽然你会被射杀。而且无人区目前还不是那种翻滚的烂泥，对吧？还能看到花朵。不，他说这是一片平坦的草地，长着矢车菊之类的植物，长草，几个弹坑，有一架飞机的残骸，他能看到铁丝网，他们的和我们的，但仅此而已。他又打了个盹，听着士兵们抱怨他们的虱子，这对他们来说是个大问题，我们等会儿会回到这个话题，然后他们在掩体里吃早餐，有培根、鸡蛋、咖啡、吐司和
would maybe talk about some of the things that have come up in Graves' accounts so far. So first of all, the trenches. So the trenches, as you said, Tom, they are relatively new. You know, when Graves arrives, they are only months old. They were improvised. They were cut into the clay and the chalk in a hurry. And a key thing for people to remember, the Allies, when they dug their trenches, did not think, well, we're going to be here four years, so we better make them good.
橘子果酱，所以还不错。就在他们大快朵颐时，邓恩的贴身男仆，他的勤务兵，一个叫金（Kingdom）的人冲了进来，他的眼睛里充满了惊恐和兴奋，他说：“有毒气，长官，有毒气，他们在用毒气。”邓恩说了一句任何人说过的最英国化的话。他说：“很好，金，把我在另一个房间的呼吸器拿来，再拿一罐果酱。”你能在戴着防毒面具的同时吃果酱吗？我想果酱肯定是首要任务，对吧？你会把它抹得到处都是，不是吗？如果你想知道接下来发生了什么，我想最好的办法是去读这本书，因为我不想把整本书都讲完。但我认为我们
they actually thought we might be here for a couple of weeks and then we're going to hopefully resume the offensive and drive the Germans further back east. And are they still thinking that at this point? I think by now, so we're in May 1915, there probably is an awareness that this is, this is why they're working so hard on the trenches that they're going to be here for a little bit longer.
也许可以谈谈格雷夫斯目前的叙述中出现的一些事情。首先，关于战壕。所以正如你所说，汤姆，这些战壕是相对较新的。你知道，当格雷夫斯到达时，它们只有几个月大。它们是临时修建的。它们是在仓促之中在粘土和白垩土中挖出来的。对人们来说，一个关键的事情要记住，盟军在挖战壕时，并没有想过，‘好吧，我们要在这里待四年，所以我们最好把它修好。’
So the way the trenches work, you've got these kind of barricades and parapets that are built really of earth, of soil and of rubble, and people would reinforce them with wooden planks and with sandbags and then they would lie in the ground of the trench with these wooden planks, these duckboards. And they gave them names. They would often name after London Street, so Oxford Street, Regent Street and whatnot. And an intersection would be named after a famous junction in London.
他们实际上认为我们可能在这里待上一两周，然后希望恢复攻势，把德国人进一步赶向东方。他们在这个时候还在这么想吗？我想现在，也就是在1915年5月，可能已经有一种意识，这就是为什么他们在战壕上工作得如此辛苦，他们要在这里多待一会儿。
So Hyde Park Corner, Oxford Circus and so on. Elephant and Castle. Yeah, I mean, I suppose, conceivably. Probably not. Probably not. And they would also make up names for the German lines opposite them. So there's a bit in Siegfried Sassoon where Siegfried Sassoon says, Our objective was pint trench,
所以战壕的运作方式是，你有这些由泥土、土壤和瓦砾真正建造的类似路障和胸墙的东西，人们用木板和沙袋加固它们，然后他们会在战壕的底部铺上这些木板，即所谓的“防潮木板”（duckboards）。他们给它们起了名字。他们经常以伦敦的街道来命名，比如牛津街、摄政街之类。一个交叉口会以伦敦著名的交通枢纽命名。
taking bitter and beer and clearing ale and vat and also Pils and Lane. So they're name them all, the German trenches all after beers. Now on the German trenches, everybody agrees the German trenches are much better. They're deeper, they are safer, they're better defended, they're more comfortable. And the reason for that, obviously, is the Germans are there for the long haul. They're like what we have we hold. So it's not just about the German. being better at building things.
比如海德公园角、牛津圆环等等。象堡（Elephant and Castle）。是的，我的意思是，我想，这完全可以想象。可能没有吧。可能没有。他们还会为他们对面的德国战线起名字。萨松（Siegfried Sassoon）的作品中有一段，萨松说，我们的目标是“品脱战壕”（pint trench），
Maybe they are better at building things, I don't know. I mean, they use some reinforced concrete, don't they? Which seems a kind of typical Hun trick. Well, when people do take German trenches, they're stunned. How good they are. They have kind of ceiling beams. They have nice sort of cladded walls. Cinemas.
拿下“苦啤酒”（bitter）、“生啤酒”（beer）、“清淡艾尔”（clearing ale）、“大桶”（vat）还有“比尔森”（Pils）和“巷道”（Lane）。所以他们把所有的德国战壕都用啤酒来命名。现在关于德国战壕，大家都承认德国战壕要好得多。它们更深，更安全，防守更好，更舒适。显然，其中的原因在于德国人要在那里进行长期作战。他们就像是“我们拥有我们所占领的”。所以这不仅仅是关于德国人更擅长建造东西。
In the dugouts, they have kind of skylights and alcoves, sort of decorative alcoves and things. And they go really deep, don't they? I mean, some of them go so deep that actually they're kind of impervious to to anything the British can fire at them? Well, this is one of the issues when the British think, oh, we'll just clear the German trenches with artillery bombardment. They don't realize just how deep-seated these German trenches are.
也许他们更擅长建造东西，我不知道。我的意思是，他们使用了一些钢筋混凝土，对吧？这似乎是一种典型的德国鬼子把戏。好吧，当人们确实占领德国战壕时，他们都惊呆了。它们太棒了。它们有某种天花板横梁。它们有漂亮的镶板墙。有电影院。
Graves talks, the one thing he obviously talks about in the trench, which is the most common thing that people associate with them, is mud. And this is the aspect of trench life that soldiers mention the most in subsequent accounts. So there's a diary of the war by a guy called Captain Alexander Stewart, which was published in 2009. He joined the Scottish Rifles in 19. He says of the mud. Mud is a bad description.
在掩体里，它们有天窗和壁龛，某种装饰性的壁龛之类的东西。它们挖得真的很深，对吧？我的意思是，其中一些深到实际上可以免疫英国人能发射的任何武器？好吧，这就是问题之一，当英国人认为，哦，我们只要用炮击清除德国战壕就行了。他们没有意识到这些德国战壕挖得有多深。
It's not mud. The soil was more like a thick slime. When walking one sank several inches, it was difficult to withdraw the feet. The consequence was that men who were standing still or sitting down got embedded in the slime and were unable to extricate themselves. And as the trenches were so shallow,
格雷夫斯谈到了他在战壕里明显谈到的一件事，这是人们将战壕联系得最多的一件事，那就是泥土。这是士兵在随后的叙述中提及最多的战壕生活的一个方面。所以有一个叫亚历山大·斯图尔特（Alexander Stewart）上尉的人写的战争日记，于2009年出版。他于1919年加入了苏格兰步兵团。他是这样形容泥土的：“泥土”是一个糟糕的描述。
they had to stay where they were all day. God, imagine being stuck there. But here's the thing. You stuck there. And if it's in the middle of a battle, you're a sitting duck. And there are a lot of a counter. actually, reading through soldiers' accounts, there's loads of them where they say
它不是泥土。土壤更像是一种浓稠的黏液。走的时候会陷下去好几英寸，很难把脚拔出来。结果就是，那些站着不动或坐着的人被嵌入了黏液中，无法自拔。由于战壕太浅，
blogs got stuck and the Germans were basically using him for target practice or sort of dropping shells getting closer and closer to him and he couldn't get out because he's stuck in all this mud. But there's worse things than mud. So Graves, remember I said he was dozing and he heard the people talking about lice. Lice are a big issue but there's also flies and fleas. So flies, Alexander Stewart again, he talks about filthy, fat, dirty flies, drawn by the dead bodies. Well, the flies must be, I mean, it must be all their Christmases come at once. Exactly, yeah.
格рей夫斯陷在泥里动弹不得，德国人基本上把他当成了活靶子，或者发射炮弹离他越来越近，而他因为深陷泥潭根本无法脱身。但比泥潭更糟糕的事还有很多。所以格里夫斯，还记得我刚才说他在打瞌睡时听到人们在谈论虱子吗？虱子是个大问题，但还有苍蝇和跳蚤。说到苍蝇，亚历山大·斯图尔特再次提到，尸体吸引了那些恶心、肥胖、肮脏的苍蝇。好吧，对苍蝇来说，这简直就像过圣诞节一样爽。完全是这样，没错。
In the company headquarters dug out, he says, they were masked on the ceiling like a swarm of bees. And when a man was asleep, they would settle all around his mouth and over his face. So the corpses would be full of maggots, I guess. Exactly. Fleas. Everybody had fleas. You pretty much got fleas within weeks. They would get into underclothes.
他在连指挥部的防空洞里说，它们像一群蜜蜂一样密密麻麻地贴在天花板上。当一个人睡着时，它们会成群结队地落在他的嘴周围和脸上。所以我想，尸体一定爬满了蛆虫。确实如此。跳蚤。每个人都有跳蚤。你基本上在几周内就会染上跳蚤。它们会钻进内衣里。
And what the soldiers would do is they would get candles. and they would kind of run the candle, the sort of lit candle along the seams of their underwear. And as one puts it, you could hear the eggs crackling as you kind of burned your own underpants with this candle. And then the lice,
士兵们会怎么做呢？他们会拿蜡烛，然后把点燃的蜡烛沿着内衣的接缝处划过。正如一个人所描述的那样，当你用蜡烛烧自己的内裤时，你能听到虫卵发出噼里啪啦的爆裂声。然后是虱子，
this is a French stretcher bearer called Raymond Clemell. He said, without telling anybody, I take my clothes off and I see hundreds of lice and lava jumping out at me. They're everywhere in my shirt, my trousers, my underwear, etc.
这是一个名叫雷蒙德·克勒梅尔的法国担架兵说的。他说，在不告诉任何人的情况下，我脱下衣服，看到数百只虱子和幼虫跳出来。我的衬衫、裤子、内衣等到处都是。
I shake my clothes as much as I can. and I finally wear them again. The only choice we have is to wait for the next relief and then to boil our clothes. So is this a regular occurrence that people are taking their clothes off and shaking the lice out, do you think? Yeah, I think it is. I mean, you're, there's no sort of personal discretion, as it were. There's not much place for that on the Western Front, really. You're going to the toilet altogether on a kind of plank and whatnot.
我尽全力抖落衣服上的脏东西，最后还是得把它们穿上。我们唯一的选择就是等待下一批换防的人来，然后把衣服煮沸。所以你认为大家脱下衣服抖掉虱子是常态吗？是的，我认为是的。我的意思是，根本没有什么所谓的个人隐私可言。在西线战场上，基本上没有这种地方。大家都是在一块木板上一起上厕所之类的。
And you'd rather be naked than bitten to death by fleas? Of course. And the lice carry something called trench fever. And trench fever is an infectious disease. It's extremely common in the trenches, and the worst cases can be fatal. So J.R. Tolkien was invalided out at the Somme with a very severe case of trench fever. And ironically, the trench fever probably saved his life because if he'd stayed in the Somme, he could easily have died. A.A. Milne had trench fever. C.S. Lewis had trench fever.
那你宁愿赤身裸体，也不愿被跳蚤咬死？当然了。而且虱子会传播一种叫作战壕热的疾病。战壕热是一种传染病。在战壕里极为常见，最严重的情况可能是致命的。因此，J.R.R.托尔金在索姆河战役中因患上严重的战壕热而被遣送回国。具有讽刺意味的是，战壕热很可能救了他的命，因为如果他继续留在索姆河，他很可能会丧命。A.A.米恩得过战壕热。C.S.刘易斯得过战壕热。
God, it's hard to think of A.A. Milne, isn't it, with trench fever? Winnie the poo with lice. He probably would have had fleas, certainly. Well, what about Winnie the Pooh with rats? So Graves has a section in his memoir where he's talking about rats, and he says there was a new officer who turned up. And his first night, he goes to bed, and he wakes and he hears this scuffle on his bed. There were two rats on his blankets tussling for the possession of a severed hand. This was thought a great joke, says Graves. And again, the rats are so common they are ubiquitous.
天哪，很难把A.A.米恩和战壕热联系在一起，对吧？长着虱子的小熊维尼。他肯定也得过跳蚤。那么，长着老鼠的小熊维尼呢？所以格里夫斯在他的回忆录里写到老鼠时说，曾有一个新军官来到这里。第一天晚上，他上床睡觉，醒来时听到床上有什么东西在争夺。他的毯子上有两只老鼠在为一个断手争夺不休。格里夫斯说，这被认为是一个天大的笑话。同样，老鼠也是如此普遍，随处可见。
So like the flies, they're drawn by the dead body. is they become huge. Because they're eating dead soldiers. Yeah. There are so many accounts of them being as big as cats. And often the men deliberately do not kill them because they will just be left there to putrify and they will stink and spread disease.
所以就像苍蝇一样，它们被尸体吸引，而且变得体型巨大。因为它们在吃死去的士兵。是的。有无数的记录说它们长得像猫一样大。而且士兵们通常故意不杀它们，因为如果把它们留在那里腐烂，它们会发出恶臭并传播疾病。
Or the dead bodice will draw other rats to kind of feed on them. So this is another Tommy writing home. In the night we have heaps of company rats and mice and the other livestock. Every time you wake, the rats are fighting and squeaking all over you. The other night, one took a flying jump onto my face. There's a famous poem by Ivan Rosenberg called Break of Day in the Trenches, which kind of almost implies a fondness for what he calls a queer sardonic rat.
或者说死去的尸体会吸引更多的老鼠来觅食。所以这是另一个写信回家的汤米（英国士兵的昵称）。在夜里，我们有成堆的老鼠、小鼠和其他伴侣。每次你醒来，老鼠都在你身上打架、吱吱叫。前天晚上，有一只老鼠猛地跳到了我的脸上。伊万·罗森伯格有一首著名的诗叫《战壕里的破晓》，几乎暗示了他对一种他称之为古怪而冷嘲热讽的老鼠的喜爱。
And he imagines the rat brushing up against his hand and then going and brushing up against a German hand. And say, droll rat, they would shoot you if they knew your cosmopolitan sympathies. So it may be that in, you know, a bit like Christopher Robin befriending, piglet. If you're in the trench, you might befriend it. My friend a rat. I mean, I think that... Well, you might, Tom. I think I draw the line of preferring a rat, frankly. I take friendship where I can get it. That's fair. All this sounds pretty nightmarish. And some listeners are thinking
他想象着老鼠擦过他的手，然后又去擦过一只德国人的手。并且说，滑稽的老鼠啊，如果他们知道你对全人类都有同情心，他们就会开枪打死你。所以也许，这有点像克里斯托弗·罗宾和皮杰交朋友。如果你在战壕里，你可能会和它交朋友。和一只老鼠交朋友。我的意思是，我认为……好吧，你可能会的，汤姆。坦白说，我觉得我绝不会更喜欢一只老鼠。我有机会就会交朋友。这倒也是。这一切听起来都像是一场噩梦。有些听众可能会想
this doesn't sound like a great laugh. So you are muddy, you're wet, you're cold, you've got rats. There's also the shells going off all around you. And it's also very boring. There's a lot of waiting around. So there's a young German writer called Ernst Junger, who we will feature more after the break. And Junger arrived very excited and very idealistic. Can't couldn't wait to get, have a crack at the British. And he said in his memoir, Storm of Steel, after only short time of the regiment, we'd become thoroughly disillusioned.
这听起来可一点都不好笑又好玩。所以你满身泥泞，又湿又冷，还冷得发抖，到处都是老鼠。周围还有炮弹在爆炸。而且也非常无聊。有大量的时间都在等待。所以有一个年轻的德国作家叫恩斯特·容格，我们将在中场休息后详细介绍他。容格到达时非常兴奋，充满了理想主义。迫不及待地想去跟英国人较量一番。他在回忆录《钢铁风暴》中说，在部队待了很短一段时间后，我们就彻底幻灭了。
Instead of the danger that we had hoped for, we'd be given dirt, work and sleepless nights. Worse still was the boredom, which was still more innovating for the soldier than the proximity of death. But one point to make as we approach the break. It's really important to say, you said earlier, it's a lot better than working down a mine. And I think you're right. And a lot of soldiers enjoy it.
没有我们所期望的危险，我们得到的只有泥土、繁重的劳务和不眠之夜。更糟糕的是无聊，对于士兵来说，这种无聊比死神临头的威胁更令人筋疲力尽。但在我们接近中场休息时，有一点需要指出。非常重要的一点是，你刚才说，这比在矿井里工作好得多。我想你是对的。而且很多士兵其实很享受这种生活。
This is a thing that I think subsequently people in the 21st century struggle to get into their heads. For a lot of soldiers, particularly working class men from poorer backgrounds who worked in factories or, you know, in mines or had backbreaking, you know, industrial jobs. The routine on the Western Front really isn't that bad. You've got four regular meals a day, breakfast, lunch, tea, day. Yeah, I mean, all that marmalade, brilliant. Yeah. But you think is the food really, it's a little bit like when we did the Titanic episodes, and we were talking about life in third class.
这是我觉得21世纪的人们后来很难理解的一点。对于许多士兵，尤其是那些来自贫困背景、在工厂或矿井工作过、或者干过繁重体力劳动的工人阶级男性来说，西线战场的例行生活其实并没有那么糟糕。你每天有四顿定时饭，早餐、午餐、茶点、晚餐。是的，我是说，所有的橘子果酱，太棒了。是的。但你觉得食物真的……这有点像我们做泰坦尼克号那集时，讨论三等舱的生活一样。
You know, it might look bad to us, but to people at the time, you're getting tins of what's called bully beef. You've got biscuits, you've got bread and jam, you have regular, you have a lot of tea, you have kind of bits of, you have rum, you have cigarette rations, all of this kind of thing. There's a lot of time for chatting and for general bantz. there's a lot of sleep you write letters
你知道，在我们看来可能很糟糕，但对当时的人们来说，你能吃上一罐被称为“咸牛肉”的东西。你有饼干，有面包和果酱，有规律的生活，有大量的茶，有各种各样的东西，有朗姆酒，有香烟配给，诸如此类。有大量的时间用来聊天和开玩笑，有很多时间睡觉，写信，
you play cards is that worse than working in a mine not necessarily no because you're on constant risk of death in a mine aren't you? Of course you are and you're outdoors and a lot of people actually love the outdoor element so here's a really good example
玩纸牌，这比在矿井里工作更糟糕吗？不一定，因为你在矿井里时刻面临着死亡的风险，不是吗？当然是的，而且你在户外，很多人其实很喜欢这种户外的元素，所以这里有一个非常好的例子，
here's like a private Ernest Todd looking back at the war and he says on a nice summer's day you could think there wasn't a war on really early in the morning you'd have the first planes coming over and a general air of barminusant ease. Breakfast would come up if there was going to be any and you would settle down to a day of laziness in the sun if you could. The lads would sit on this firestep and talk and sing. Towards the evening they get sentimental talking about their homes.
比如二等兵欧内斯特·托德回忆起战争时说，在一个美好的夏日，你真的会觉得好像没有发生战争一样。一大早，你就会看到第一批飞机飞过，周围弥漫着一种漫不经心的轻松气氛。如果有早餐的话，早餐会送上来，如果可以的话，你就会安顿下来，在阳光下懒洋洋地过上一天。小伙子们会坐在火踏板上聊天、唱歌。到了傍晚，他们会开始多愁善感地谈论自己的家乡。
Yes, during those summer months of 1915 you could forget that there was a war on. You really could. And part of the reason for that is actually you think of the First World War and you think of the trenches and you sort of imagine that people just either digging or or they're going over the top. But actually, a Tommy, a British soldier, spends less than half of his time on the front line. He spends three-fifths of his time in the rear. And what they're doing in the rear, they're just hanging about.
是的，在1915年的那些夏日里，你真的会忘记战争的存在。你真的会忘。部分原因其实是，一提到第一次世界大战和战壕，你就会想象人们要么在挖土，要么在发起冲锋。但实际上，一个汤米（英国士兵），花在最前线的时间还不到他全部时间的一半。他五分之三的时间都在后方度过。他们在后方做的事，其实就是闲逛。
They're playing football. They go to film screenings. There are special concerts put on for them. They go to plays. There are people organise lectures and debates. They're reading. There's some graves in his book. a recounts a cricket match
他们踢足球。他们去看电影放映。有专门为他们举办的音乐会。他们去看戏剧。有人组织讲座和辩论。他们在读书。格里夫斯在他的书里，讲述了一场板球比赛，
where they they use I think a dead parrot in a cage as the wicket and then they get kind of straff by a plane so machine gun fire
他们把一个笼子里死去的鹦鹉当作球门，然后遭到一架飞机的扫射，所以机枪扫射
stops play but it's nice to think it's not so muddy that you can't you can't play cricket there's loads of stuff like that I mean I think the reason they play football
打断了比赛，但想想看，这里没有泥泞到连板球都打不了，这种事多得是，我是说，我觉得他们踢足球
more famously rather than cricket is that it's easier to play football yeah jumpers for goalposts exactly but there's also I think a real sense
比打板球更出名、更频繁的原因是，踢足球更容易些，对吧，用毛衣当球门柱，完全是这样。但我也觉得有一种真实的
of camaraderie. Again, you get that in Graves' book, you know, the affectionate way that he talks about his platoon, this sort of sense that, I mean, this is one of the most common things that people said afterwards about life in the trenches, that barriers of class and region and indeed nation within the United Kingdom end up being broken down. So to quote William Holmes of the London Regiments, I mean, this is all kind of cliched stuff, but of course this is how people spoke and indeed speak today. We knew we were there to do that job and we were so fond of our country and we were like a lot of brothers today. We were just like a band of brothers.
袍泽之情。同样，你在格里夫斯的书里也能感受到这一点，你知道，他谈论自己排的那些充满温情的话语，这种感觉——我的意思是，这是人们后来关于战壕生活说得最多的一点，英国国内阶级、地区甚至民族的隔阂最终都被打破了。借用伦敦团的威廉·霍尔姆斯的话来说，我的意思是，这些都是陈词滥调，但当时的人们确实是这么说的，今天也依然如此。我们知道我们去那里是为了完成那个任务，我们是如此深爱我们的国家，我们就像今天的许多兄弟一样。我们就像是一群兄弟。
Oh, well, sweet. Nelson would have been proud, Tom. Yeah, well, like Hashingkor, which is not far from where they're stationed, does me. Not far at all. But, of course, there is one aspect of life on the Western Brother that we haven't mentioned at all, because they haven't actually been sent there to have a holiday. No. They haven't actually been sent there to make friends with people from other towns and to play football.
哦，真甜蜜。纳尔逊勋爵会为之骄傲的，汤姆。是的，就像离他们驻扎地不远的海星村一样，真让我受不了。一点也不远。但是，当然，西线兄弟们的生活中还有一个我们根本没有提及的方面，因为他们实际上并不是被派去度假的。没有。他们实际上并不是被派去和来自其他城镇的人交朋友并踢足球的。
They have been sent there for one reason and one reason only, which is to fight and kill the enemy. So, what was it like to go over the top to kill another human being in your country's name? And are the Germans about to unleash a secret weapon to end the deadlock in the trenches and win the war? Tom, we'll find out after the break. This episode is brought to you by the Times and by the Sunday Times. Now, if there is one thing that history, and indeed Bob Dylan, teaches us, it is that the Times they are. always are changing. And Dominic, I guess we're living in changing times now, what with America attacking Iran and oil crises. So do you think that the lessons of that for Kirstama are
他们被派到那里只有一个原因，而且是唯一的原由，那就是去战斗并杀死敌人。所以，为了你祖国的名义去冲锋陷阵并杀死另一个人类，那是一种什么样的体验？德国人是否即将释放一种秘密武器来打破战壕里的僵局并赢得战争？汤姆，我们中场休息后揭晓。本节目由《泰晤士报》和《星期日泰晤士报》赞助播出。如果说历史以及鲍勃·迪伦教会了我们什么的话，那就是《泰晤士报》所揭示的，时代总是在变。多米尼克，我想我们现在正生活在一个不断变化的时代，美国袭击伊朗，还有石油危机。所以你觉得这对基尔斯塔默有什么启示？
Rosie? So looking at the career of Edward Heath, for instance, who was prime minister in the previous oil crisis? It didn't work out brilliantly for Ted Heath, to be honest. Actually, he and Kirstarmer, I think, are quite similar. They're from relatively humble backgrounds, and there's a slight sense of floundering, which they have in common. Their bigger point is you never really know what's around the corner, do you? Because when you look at history, the future is always pretty uncertain. But, you know, the facts, they shouldn't be uncertain. And that, of course, is where the Times and the Sunday Times come in.
罗西？因此，回顾一下爱德华·希特的职业生涯，例如，他在上一次石油危机时担任首相？老实说，这对特德·希特来说结果并不是特别好。实际上，他和基尔斯塔默，我认为他们非常相似。他们都出身于相对卑微的背景，而且他们身上都有某种不知所措的共同感。他们更深刻的观点是，你永远不知道转角会遇到什么，对吧？因为当你回顾历史时，未来总是相当不确定的。但是，你知道，事实不应该是这样的，不确定性是不应该存在的。当然，这就是《泰晤士报》和《星期日泰晤士报》发挥作用的地方。
Yeah, and I would say that understanding the news is absolutely vital when you're navigating an increasingly uncertain and unpredictable world. So to subscribe to the Times and the Sunday Times, visit the Times.com. Come on man, get up. We're moving out. I woke up in dew sodden grass. Through a stuttering swath of machine gun fire, we plunged back into our communication trench and moved to a position on the edge of the wood previously held by the French. A sweetish smell and a bundle hanging in the wire caught my attention. In the rising mist, I leaped out of the trench and found a shrunken, French corpse. Flesh like mouldering fish gleamed greenishly through splits in the shredded uniform.
是的，我想说的是，在 navigating（应对）一个日益不确定且不可预测的世界时，理解新闻绝对是至关重要的。因此，要想订阅《泰晤士报》和《星期日泰晤士报》，请访问 thetimes.com。拜托老兄，起来吧。我们要转移了。我在露水浸湿的草地上醒来。穿过断断续续的机枪火力网，我们重新冲回交通壕，转移到树林边缘的一个阵地，那里之前由法军控制。一股甜腻的气味和一个挂在铁丝网上的包裹引起了我的注意。在升起的晨雾中，我跳出战壕，发现了一具干瘪的法国士兵尸体。破烂的军服裂开处，露出了像腐烂鱼肉般泛着绿色微光的皮肉。
Turning round, I took a step back in horror. Next to me a figure was crouched against a tree. It still had gleaming French leather harness, and on its back was a fully packed haversack, topped by a round mess tin, empty eye sockets, and a few strymed. bands of hair on the bluish black skull indicated that the man was not among the living. So that was a German, obviously, and it's a man we've already met in the first half, the writer Ernst Junger, and he's describing the fighting at Les Epage near Verdun in April 1915, and it comes from his memoir, Storm of Steel, which is one of the great war memoirs, not just of the First World War, but of all time, isn't it?
转过身，我惊恐地向后退了一步。我旁边有一个身影蜷缩在一棵树旁。它仍然穿着闪闪发光的法国皮革背带，背上背着一个装满东西的背包，背包顶部是一个圆形的饭盒，空洞的眼眶，还有青黑色头骨上仅存的几缕头发，表明这个人已经不在人世了。显然，那是一个德国人，也就是我们在前半部分已经见过的作家恩斯特·容格。他正在描述1915年4月凡尔登附近的莱斯埃帕日（Les Eparges）的战斗。这段内容出自他的回忆录《钢铁风暴》，这是伟大的战争回忆录之一，不仅是一战中，而且是有史以来最伟大的战争回忆录之一，对吧？
So Dominic, probably worth giving a character sketch. I mean, he's an amazing, amazing man. Extraordinary life. He has an incredible life, Ernst Junger. You know, you can trace the whole of German 20th century history through his life, really. He was born in Heidelberg in 1895, and his father was a rich kind of chemist, kind of chemical engineer. And he went to boarding school, like Robert Graves. But he was typical of kind of German youth before the first World War. He joined a nationalist youth group called the Wondervigel.
所以多米尼克，也许值得为他做一个生平画像。我的意思是，他是一个了不起、了不起的人。人生极其不凡。恩斯特·容格有着不可思议的一生。你知道，你真的可以通过他的人生轨迹来了解整个德国20世纪的历史。他1895年出生于海德堡，他的父亲是一位富有的化学家，某种程度上的化学工程师。他和罗伯特·格里夫斯一样去寄宿学校。但他是一战前典型的那种德国青年。他加入了一个名为“万德维格尔”（Wandervogel）的民族主义青年组织。
So they're kind of these sort of wandering birds. They're a little bit like the Boy Scouts, but they're more nationalistic and more kind of idealistic in a way. Then he ran away to join the French Foreign Legion. And then he came back. And then on the 1st of August 1914, that's the day Germany entered the war, he joined up. He was so keen to get stuck in. So he's 19, like graves. And later on, after he'd published this book, Storm of Steel, he became this incredibly controversial German literary figure. So all through his life, he was very militaristic and very nationalistic, but he never joined the Nazis. He did serve as an army captain in Paris in the 1940s, but he was appalled by the anti-Semitism of the Nazis, even though he'd himself
所以他们有点像是那种四处流浪的鸟儿。他们有点像童子军，但从某种意义上说，他们更具民族主义色彩，也更具理想主义。后来他逃跑去加入了法国外籍军团。然后他又回来了。接着在1914年8月1日，也就是德国参战的那天，他参军了。他太渴望投入战斗了。所以他19岁，和格里夫斯一样。后来，在他出版了这本书《钢铁风暴》之后，他成为了一个极其具有争议的德国文学人物。所以在他的一生中，他一直非常崇尚军国主义和民族主义，但他从未加入纳粹党。他在20世纪40年代确实曾在巴黎担任过陆军上尉，但他对纳粹的反犹太主义感到震惊，尽管他在20年代自己也曾
being pretty anti-Semitic in the 20s. He then was quite close to the Staufenberg plotters, so the people who tried to blow Hitler up in 1944, he was thrown out of the army but not executed. He becomes an early enthusiast for LSD. He does, exactly. And also he's very keen entomologist. He had an inordinate fondness for beetles.
相当反犹。后来他与施陶芬贝格密谋集团关系密切，也就是1944年试图炸死希特勒的那群人，他被开除出军队但没有被处刑。他后来成为了LSD（致幻剂）的早期狂热爱好者。他的确如此，没错。而且他也是一个非常狂热的昆虫学家。他对甲虫有着异乎寻常的喜爱。
I think he had about seven types of beetle named after him or something improbable. And then he died at the age of 102, so in I think, 1998. God, that's mad, isn't it? Yeah, crazy. Anyway, Storm of Steel, his book, which I really recommend is, it's very different in tone from Robert Graves' memoir, even though they're at the same age and they're writing about exactly the same point in time. Because Younger is much more interested in what it's like of the excitement and the adrenaline and the experience of fighting and battle. So it really captures his book, the adrenaline, the noise, the sensations, and this sort of dreamlike confusion and surrealism, which you had a sort of taste of there when he sees those French bodies.
我想大约有七种甲虫是以他的名字命名的，或者有类似不太可能的事情。然后他在102岁时去世，我想那是在1998年。天哪，太疯狂了，对吧？是的，太疯狂了。无论如何，他的书《钢铁风暴》我极力推荐，它的基调与罗伯特·格里夫斯的回忆录截然不同，尽管他们年龄相仿，写的是完全同一个时间点的事情。因为容格对战斗和战争带来的兴奋、肾上腺素飙升以及战斗体验更感兴趣。所以他的书真正捕捉到了肾上腺素、噪音、感官体验，以及那种如梦般的混乱和超现实主义，当他看到那些法国士兵的尸体时，你就能在某种程度上体会到这一点。
So in this particular occasion, we're in April 1915. His units has been pushed forward into the French lines. So the Germans have punched a little hole in the French lines and his units have been thrown in. And this is his first experience of battle. And he's in this trench and it's full of dead Frenchmen. Rotted, dried, stiffened to mummies, frozen in an eerie dance of death. Such an eerie image, isn't it? It is.
所以在特定的这一次，也就是1915年4月。他的部队被推进到了法军防线。德军在法军防线上撕开了一个小口子，他的部队就被派了上去。这是他第一次经历战斗。他待在战壕里，里面全是死去的法国士兵。腐烂、干瘪、僵硬如木乃伊，在诡异的死亡之舞中凝固。多么诡异的画面，不是吗？确实是。
But the really eerie thing, he realizes that they've been there for ages. and that the French must have just not bothered to bury. Poor from the French, I think, not to bury their dead. Anyway, they haven't buried these books. Well, especially since the same muddy, you just roll them and they can sink into the glute. So what he does, you know, don't forget this is the middle of a battle. He has a little stroll. He looks for souvenirs.
但真正诡异的是，他意识到这些人已经死在那儿很久了。而法国人竟然懒得去掩埋他们。我觉得法国人连死者都不埋，实在太糟糕了。不管怎样，他们没有埋葬这些人。尤其是考虑到同样的泥地里，你只要滚一下，它们就会陷进淤泥里。所以他做了什么，别忘了这可是激战正酣的时候。他散了会儿步。他寻找着纪念品。
He finds, again, this sort of dreamlike quality. He finds a suitcase that's sort of been blown open. And one of the things in the suitcase is this beautiful striped shirt. And he takes off his army tunic and he puts the shirt on. I relished the pleasant tickle of clean cloth against my skin, he said. He lights up his pipe. He has a smoke. Then he hears the guns starting up again, what he calls a savage pounding dance.
他又找到了这种如梦似幻的感觉。他发现了一个被炸开的皮箱。皮箱里的东西之一是一件漂亮的条纹衬衫。他脱下军装，换上了这件衬衫。“我享受着干净布料贴着皮肤的舒适触感，”他说。他点燃烟斗。抽了一口烟。然后他听到枪声再次响起，也就是他所说的“狂野的捶击之舞”。
And eventually he hears someone calling. It's basically one of the officers saying, come on, on your feet. All of you get ready. They form up again. They go out of the trench and into a wood. You know, they have no idea where they are, where they're going. They're just following orders as people do. So it's very dreamlike still.
最后他听到有人在喊。基本上是一个军官在说，来吧，站起来。大家准备好。他们重新列队。他们走出战壕，进入了一片树林。你知道，他们根本不知道自己在哪里，要去哪里。他们就像普通人一样只是在听从命令。所以这仍然非常像是一场梦。
They go into this woods, they go into a clearing and they sit down. The sun is setting. They're just sort of chatting. And they think, well, this is probably it for today. And it's at this point. It's a fantastic scene in the book. He says, Our ribble conversations were suddenly cut off by a marrow freezing cry.
他们走进这片树林，来到一片空地，然后坐了下来。太阳正在落山。他们就在那儿闲聊。他们觉得，今天大概就这样了。就在这个时候。书里有一个精彩的场景。他说：“我们漫无边际的谈话突然被一声让人毛骨悚然的尖叫声打断了。”
20 yards behind us, clumps of earth whirled up out of a white cloud and smacked into the boughs. The crash echoed through the woods. Stricken eyes looked at each other. bodies press themselves into the ground. And then there's this series of explosions. He says choking gases drifted through the undergrowth, smoke obscured the tree tops. There are trees crashing down, there screams.
离我们20码远的地方，成团的泥土从一团白烟中腾空而起，狠狠砸在树枝上。剧烈的爆炸声在树林中回荡。惊恐的眼神互相看着。身体拼命贴向地面。接着是一连串的爆炸。他说，窒息性的毒气在灌木丛中弥漫，浓烟遮蔽了树顶。树木轰然倒塌，伴随着阵阵尖叫。
We leaped up and ran blindly from tree to tree. Like looking for cover. They're like frightened game, he says. And in the middle of all this, he feels a blow on his left thigh. And this is a piece of shrapnel that's come from one of the explosions and has basically sliced into his leg. and he drops his pack, he throws down his pack, and he runs back to the trench that they all come from.
我们跳起来，在树与树之间盲目地奔跑。就像在寻找掩护。他们就像受到惊吓的猎物，他说。正当这一切发生时，他感到左大腿挨了一下。这是一块弹片，来自其中一次爆炸，直接切入了他的腿。他扔下背包，扔下背包，然后跑回他们出发时的那条战壕。
The trench was appalling, choked with seriously wounded and dying men. A figure stripped to the waist with a ripped open back, leaned against the parapet. Another with a triangular flap hanging off the back of his skull, emitted short, high-pitched screams. And then this incredible line. This was the home of the great God pain, and for the first time I looked through a devilish chink, into the depths of his realm.
战壕里惨不忍睹，挤满了重伤员和垂死的人。一个腰部以上赤裸、后背被撕裂的人靠在胸墙上。另一个人脑后挂着一块三角形的头皮，发出短促而高亢的尖叫。接着是这句令人惊叹的话。这是痛苦之伟大神的家园，我第一次透过一条魔鬼般的缝隙，窥视了他领域的深处。
Very evocative writing. So he carries on running through the trench in this sort of panic, blood streaming from his leg. He eventually collapses. Afterwards, when it's died down, he's found by stretcher-bearers and he's taken to a dressing station.
非常具有感染力的文字。于是他带着腿上流淌的鲜血，恐慌地继续在战壕里奔跑。他最终瘫倒在地。事后，当枪声平息时，他被担架员发现，并被送往包扎所。
And then eventually he is put on a train to go all the way home to Germany into his hometown of Heidelberg. But then he comes back, doesn't he? And he just keeps getting wounded throughout the war. And don't the Germans have kind of weird thing you get a medal for every wound you have?
最后，他被送上一辆火车，一路回家回到了德国，回到了他的家乡海德堡。但后来他又回来了，不是吗？而且在整个战争期间，他 계속（不断）受伤。而且德国人是不是有一种奇怪的规定，你受一次伤就能得到一枚勋章？
And he ends up with, I think, the gold medal for having been shot 10 times or whatever. He's incredibly brave, and he loves it. You know, when we're describing this, the great God pain, blokes with their heads, the heart kind of blown open and all of this. You might think, gosh, how horrific, how terrible. What an unbelievably awful scene, a nightmare. But it actually makes Younger feel more enthusiastic about the war, not less. Because it makes him feel alive?
最后，我想他获得了金质勋章，因为他中弹了10次还是多少次。他极其勇敢，而且他乐在其中。你知道，当我们描述这个时，痛苦之伟大神，那些脑袋被炸开的家伙以及所有这些。你可能会想，天哪，多么可怕，多么糟糕。这是一个令人难以置信的糟糕场景，一场噩梦。但实际上这让容格对战争更加热情，而不是减少。因为这让他感到活着？
Yeah, it makes it feel alive. It's a kind of intensity of experience that he wouldn't have had otherwise. And when he gets back to Germany, so on that break, you might think when he goes back, invalided out, you know, it would make him dread to go back. Not a bit of it. He says, to go back and to see his native land, makes him feel that Germany is eminently worth our blood and our lives. For the first time, I sense that this war was more than just a great adventure. So it's a great adventure, but it's even better than that because it's in the noble cause. And the other thing that strikes him, at the end of this scene, which is brilliantly done, you know, he's seen people. killed, he's seen combat, he's seen explosions and stuff, but he's seen dead French, but he hasn't seen a single live Frenchman. He hasn't seen a single live opponent. And actually, you could go through the war for a very long time and you could see people shot around you and you could shoot, you know, you could cause death to other people, but you might never actually lay eyes upon them in. That's one of the great innovations,
对，这让他感到活着。这是一种强烈的体验，如果不是这样他根本不会有。当他回到德国时，在那个假期里，你可能会想，当他因伤退役回家时，这会让他害怕回去。一点也没有。他说，回到这里看到自己的祖国，让他觉得德国绝对值得我们流血牺牲。我第一次感觉到，这场战争不仅仅是一场伟大的冒险。所以这是一场伟大的冒险，但它甚至比那更好，因为它是为了一个崇高的大义。另一件让他震惊的事，在这个场景的结尾，写得非常精彩，你知道，他见过人们被杀，他见过战斗，他见过爆炸等等，但他见过死去的法国人，却没有见过一个活着的法国人。他没有见过一个活着的敌人。实际上，你可以经历很长一段时间的战争，你可以看到身边的人中弹，你可以开枪，你知道，你可以致他人于死地，但你可能永远也见不到他们的真容。这是我认为第一次世界大战的伟大创新之一，
I think, of the First World War. Because death is coming from a distance or it's coming from the lice or the rats or whatever, you know, it's kind of basalaya and stuff. And both these things are very typical. So first of all, most soldiers never engage in hand-to-hand combat. And actually, when you look at the stats, it is clear most soldiers never killed anybody. And in fact, two-thirds of the casualties in the First World War were caused by artillery fire. They're not caused by one person, as it were, deliberately killing another person that they can see in front of them. And Younger is not untypical in finding battle enjoyable.
因为死亡来自远方，或者来自虱子、老鼠之类的不速之客，你知道，这有点像巴萨莱亚之类的事。这两点都非常典型。首先，大多数士兵从未参与过近身肉搏。实际上，当你查看统计数据时，很明显大多数士兵从未杀死过任何人。事实上，第一次世界大战中三分之二的伤亡是由炮火造成的。它们不是由某个人造成的，可以说是故意杀害他们眼前看得见的人。容格觉得战斗很有趣，这并非不典型。
So there's an example that reminded me of one of our goalhanger comrades, Tom. So I'm an uncle Julian Grenfell who went to Eton and Balliol like Rory Stewart. And he was killed on the Western Front in May 1915. And before he was killed, he wrote to his parents, I adore war. It is like a big picnic. The fighting excitement vitalizes everything, every sight and action. And then this incredible light.
所以有一个例子让我想起了我们的高吊（Goalhanger）战友汤姆。我是朱利安·格伦费尔（Julian Grenfell）的叔叔，他像罗里·斯图尔特（Rory Stewart）一样去了伊顿公学和贝利奥尔学院。他在1915年5月阵亡于西线。在他牺牲之前，他写信给父母：“我热爱战争。这就像是一场盛大的野餐。战斗的兴奋感让一切都充满活力，每一个景象和行动。”然后是这句不可思议的话。
One loves one's fellow man so much more when one is bent on killing him. Because he was a poet. Wasn't he as well? He was a poet. Yeah. Because he was also a professional soldier. Do you think that might have made a difference? Is he more seasoned?
当一个人决心杀死另一个人时，他会更加热爱自己的同胞。因为他是个诗人。难道他不是吗？他也是个诗人。是的。因为他同时也是一名职业军人。你觉得这可能会带来不同吗？他更有经验吗？
Comes perhaps as less of a shock to him because he's already fought in battle. Maybe. I don't know. I think there are a lot of people. I think it's a question of temperament as much as everything. I think you don't know until you get there, actually. It's like that classic thing about what makes you're a coward or brave. You don't know until you've been in that environment.
对他来说可能受到的冲击较小，因为他已经在战场上战斗过了。也许吧。我不知道。我认为这很大程度上是一个性格问题。实际上，在你亲身经历之前，你根本无从得知。就像那个关于是什么让你成为胆小鬼还是勇士的经典问题。在进入那个环境之前，你根本无从得知。
You can do all the training in the world. But it comes down to. I don't know, you can be conditioned, I suppose. I guess military historians would say you can be conditioned. But, I don't know. I mean, not everybody's like this. So there's a brilliant account by a German sergeant called Stefan Vestman, who went on to be a Harley Street doctor,
你可以做世界上所有的训练。但归根结底。我不知道，我想你可以被塑造成某种样子。我想军事历史学家会说你是可以被塑造的。但是，我不知道。我的意思是，并非所有人都这样。有一个叫斯特凡·韦斯特曼（Stefan Vestman）的德国中士，他后来成为了一名哈雷街的医生，
and he was interviewed by the BBC for their brilliant series about the Great War in the 1960s. And he describes in this interview, storming enemy trenches, and he suddenly comes face to, he's a very young man, and he suddenly comes face to, face with a French soldier. And he said, I'm actually not going to do the accent because it's a very moving kind of quote. And he said, I realized that he was after my life exactly as I was after his,
他在20世纪60年代被BBC采访，谈到了他们关于第一次世界大战的精彩系列节目。他在这次采访中描述了冲锋敌方战壕的情景，他突然迎面遇上——他当时非常年轻——他突然迎面遇上了一名法国士兵。他说，我其实不打算模仿口音，因为这是一段非常感人的引言。他说：“我意识到他想要我的命，正如我想要他的命一样，
but I was quicker than he was. I pushed his rifle away and I ran my bayonet through his chest. He fell, putting his hand on the place where I'd hit him and then I thrust again. Blood came out of his mouth and he died. I nearly vomited. My knees was shaking. And they asked me, what's the matter with you. They is his comrades. And he goes on to say, his comrades were absolutely undisturbed by what had happened. One of them boasted that he had killed a Puelu, that's a Frenchman, with the butt of his rifle. Another one had strangled a French captain. A third had hit somebody over the head with his spade. They were ordinary men like me. One was a tram conductor, another a commercial traveller. Two were students, the rest
但我比他更快。我拨开他的步枪，把刺刀刺进了他的胸膛。他倒了下去，把手按在我击中的地方，然后我又刺了一次。鲜血从他口中涌出，他死了。我差一点吐出来。我的膝盖在发抖。”他们问我，“你怎么了？”“他们”指的是他的战友。他接着说，他的战友对发生的一切完全无动于衷。其中一个人吹嘘说，他用步枪枪托杀死了一个“普鲁”（Puelu，对法国士兵的蔑称）。另一个人勒死了一个法国上尉。第三个人用铲子敲了一个人的头。他们和我一样是普通人。一个是电车售票员，另一个是商业旅行者。两个是学生，其余的是
farm workers, ordinary people who would never have thought to harm anybody. So another words, these are people who would never have hit somebody over the head with a spade or strangled them in real life, in civilian life, but they've been thrust into this environment and they found something in themselves that they didn't know they had. But Stefan Vestman, who's a sergeant, you know, he's got a job that involves a degree of responsibility. He doesn't have that. He says, I woke up at night sometimes drenched in sweat because I saw the eyes of my fallen adversary. Oh, so it's like the, um, the Wilfred Owen poem where, what's it, I am, the enemy. I own the enemy you killed, my friend.
农场工人，普通人，在现实生活中、在平民生活中永远不会想到去伤害任何人。换句话说，这些人如果在现实生活或平民生活中，绝不会用铲子敲别人的脑袋或勒死他们，但他们被推入了这样的环境，却在自己身上发现了一些他们自己都不知道的东西。但是斯特凡·韦斯特曼，他是一个中士，你知道，他的工作需要一定程度的责任感。他没有那种冷漠。他说：“我有时会在半夜醒来，浑身是汗，因为我看到了我阵亡对手的眼睛。”哦，所以这就像……呃，威尔弗雷德·欧文（Wilfred Owen）的那首诗，怎么说来着，我就是敌人。我拥有你杀死的敌人，我的朋友。
Exactly. Really moving and strange poem. They sees him in a dream, doesn't he? The man that he had killed. Yeah, at the end of a long tunnel. And I suppose whether you kill or not, you just have to get used to the fact there's going to be a lot of death and a lot of killing.
没错。非常感人和奇特的一首诗。他在梦中见到了他，不是吗？那个他杀死的男人。对，在一条长长的隧道的尽头。我想，不管你杀没杀人，你都得习惯这样一个事实：这里将会有大量的死亡和大量的杀戮。
We were talking about the trenches. I mean, one thing we didn't mention, the fighting can be so fierce sometimes that it's impossible to clear the bodies. They either left in no man's land or they're hastily buried in the side of the trenches. So people will write home, this is an example, a guy from the Argyn and Sutherland Highlanders, Captain Aden Lidl,
我们刚才在谈论战壕。我的意思是，有一点我们没有提到，战斗有时会如此激烈，以至于根本无法清理尸体。他们要么被留在无人区，要么被草草埋在战壕的侧壁里。所以人们会写信回家，这是一个例子，一个来自阿盖尔和萨瑟兰高地团的家伙，阿登·利德尔（Aden Lidl）上尉，
he's writing unbelievably to his mother, and he says all the ground is full of dead bodies, and when the wall of a dugout falls in, there's generally a body exposed. One man wanted to cut the ends of some roots that were sticking out of his dugout wall. He discovered they were a corpse's fingers. Because I see on this, lots of exclamation marks after that. How about that, Mata? Imagine writing that to your mum. And then there's a French soldier.
他难以置信地写信给他的母亲，他说所有的地面都布满了尸体，当一个掩体的墙壁塌陷时，通常会露出一具尸体。有个男人想剪掉从掩体墙壁里伸出来的一些树根。他发现那是具尸体的手指。因为我看到这里有很多感叹号。这怎么样，玛塔？想象一下写信向你妈妈汇报这个。然后是一个法国士兵。
He describes have just outside their trench. Dead bodies lay for a month. One evening, Jacques on patrol saw enormous rats fleeing from under their faded coats. They were fat from human meat. His heart pounding, he crawled towards a dead man. This is Jack who's on patrol. His helmet had rolled away. He was showing a grimacing face with no flesh.
他描述了战壕外的情景。尸体躺了一个月。一天晚上，雅克在巡逻时看到巨大的老鼠从它们褪色的外套下逃窜。它们吃人肉吃得胖乎乎的。他心跳加速，向一具尸体爬去。这是正在巡逻的雅克。他的头盔滚开了。他露出一张没有肉、面目狰狞的脸。
His skull bear, his eyes eaten. A denture had slid onto his rotting shirt. And out of his gaping mouth, a foul animal jumped. Oh, God. Yeah, really, really grim. But what are the chances that you might end up like that, Tom? In my case, I think fairly high. No, they're smaller than you think.
他的头骨光秃秃的，眼睛被吃掉了。一副假牙滑落到他腐烂的衬衫上。一只肮脏的动物从他张大的嘴里跳了出来。哦，天哪。是的，真的，真的很残酷。但是你最后可能会变成那样的几率有多大，汤姆？就我而言，我认为相当高。不，它们比你想象的要小。
They're much smaller than you think. So I fell down a massive rabbit hole. There are tons and tons of articles online about this. I have people who know far more about it, A, than I do, and B, I think, than is healthy for any human being. And generally, the odds of death for a British soldier on the Western Front, in the front line, are about 10. 10%. So 9 out of 10 people there will live and one will die. And that is a lot better than the Crimean War where basically 2 out of 10 died. Well, the Battle of Can I. Right. Where, you know, lots and lots of people die. But if you're French, the odds are higher, 20% of French soldiers
它们比你想象的要小得多.所以我掉进了一个巨大的兔子洞里。网上有成吨成吨关于这个的文章。有些人对此了解得比我多得多，A，比我多，B，我认为，比任何人类健康的程度都要多。一般来说，西线英国士兵在前线阵亡的几率约为10%。也就是10%。所以那里的9个人会活下来，1个人会死亡。这比克里米亚战争要好得多，克里米亚战争中基本上每10个人里就有2个人死亡。嗯，卡尼战役。没错。在那里，有非常非常多的人死亡。但如果你是法国人，几率更高，20%的法国士兵
die and about 25% of Germans. And why the difference? I was thinking about this. Why is this? Well, the Germans obviously lose the war. I mean, that is a pretty big, a big difference. And of course, they lose it in circumstances where they launch a massive offensive. Lots of you are shot when you're attacking. So they launch a massive offensive in 1918. They're driven back and a lot of them die in that in the course of
会死，大约25%的德国人会死。为什么会有差异？我一直在思考这个问题。为什么会这样？嗯，德国人显然输掉了战争。我的意思是，这是一个相当大的、巨大的差异。当然，他们是在发动大规模进攻的情况下输掉的。进攻时会有很多人被射杀。所以在1918年，他们发动了大规模进攻。他们被击退了，其中许多人在那场战斗中丧生
2018. The French... I suppose the British don't have a Verdun, do they? The Som is pretty bad, but Verdun is a charnel house. Well, we were talking about that maybe next year in 2027 when we get to 1916. So a lot die at Verdun, I suppose. I mean, I don't have an answer, actually. Maybe military historians will have an answer about this big difference.
2018年。法国人……我想英国人没有凡尔登那样的战役，对吧？索姆河战役已经够惨了，但凡尔登简直就是个屠宰场。嗯，我们可能在明年，也就是2027年，当我们聊到1916年时会谈到这一点。所以我想很多人死在了凡尔登。我的意思是，我其实没有答案。也许军事历史学家会对这个巨大的差异有答案。
But the chances are that you would be a casualty one way or another. So almost every soldier on the front line gets wounded one way or another and or they come down with disease. You know, at some point you will get trench fever, dysentery, you'll be invalided out at some stage, probably. And of course, the difference between this war and previous wars that the dangers are not merely physical. So this is shell shock. Yeah. As one French trench journal, Les Sussis, quoted by Neil Ferguson,
但你横竖都会成为伤亡人员的几率很高。所以前线几乎每个士兵都会以这样或那样的方式受伤，或者他们会染上疾病。你知道，在某个时刻你会得战壕热、痢疾，可能在某个阶段你会因伤退役。当然，这场战争与以前战争的区别在于，危险不仅仅是身体上的。这就是所谓的战争神经官能症（炮弹休克）。是的。正如尼尔·弗格森（Neil Ferguson）引用的法国战壕期刊《Les Sussis》所说，
this book, The Pity of War, describes the shelling as a form of torture that the soldier cannot see the end of. And this is one thing I think, you know, we can imagine what it's like to be very muddy or we can imagine the horror of all the flies or something. But I guess it's probably very hard for us to imagine what it's like to be under shell fire for hours
他的书《战争的悲剧》（The Pity of War）将炮击描述为一种士兵看不到尽头的酷刑。这是我认为的一点，你知道，我们可以想象浑身是泥是什么感觉，或者我们可以想象苍蝇成群的恐怖之类的情景。但我想我们可能很难想象，连续几个小时、几天置身于炮火之下是什么感觉
and hours or days and days. They're sort of relentless, relentless pounding. Ernst Junger in Storm of Steel has this very famous description. You must imagine you're securely tied to a post, being menaced by a man swinging a heavy hammer. Now the hammer has been taken back over his head ready to be swung. Now it's cleaving the air towards you on the point of touching your skull. Then it has struck the post and the splinters are flying.
连续几个小时或几天。那种无情、无休止的轰炸。《铁雨之中》（Storm of Steel）的作者恩斯特·荣格（Ernst Junger）有这样一段非常著名的描述。你必须想象自己被紧紧绑在一根柱子上，受到一个挥舞着沉重锤子的男人的威胁。现在锤子已经高高举过头顶，准备挥下。现在它正劈开空气向你袭来，眼看就要触及你的头骨。接着它击中了柱子，木屑四处飞溅。
That is what it is like to experience heavy shelling in an exposed position. the poet Siegfried Sassoon. He arrived in France towards the end of 1915 and became friends with Robert Graves and was decorated for his exceptional bravery. He has these lines in one of his poems. Oh Christ, I want to go out and screech at them to stop. I'm going crazy. I'm going stark, staring mad because of the guns. And this, of course, is not uncommon. So even before the end of 1914, only months into the war, there are the start to be reports. of a lot of British soldiers reporting to the sick bay saying, I feel dizzy, they're trembling and they don't know why. They have headaches. They have kind of nervous symptoms, as they were called at the time. And the term shell shock was coined in February, 1915, in an article in The Lancet, the medical journal,
这就是身处开阔阵地遭遇猛烈炮击时的感受。诗人西格弗里德·萨松（Siegfried Sassoon）于1915年底抵达法国，与罗伯特·格雷夫斯（Robert Graves）结为好友，并因极其勇敢而获得勋章。他的某一首诗中有这样几行：哦，基督，我想走出去，向他们尖叫着让他们停下来。我快疯了。因为那些大炮，我正变得僵直、瞪大双眼、彻底发疯。当然，这种情况并不少见。因此，甚至在1914年底之前，也就是战争爆发仅几个月后，就开始出现报告了。许多英国士兵前往病房报告说，我感到头晕，他们在颤抖，却不知道为什么。他们头痛。正如当时所称的那样，他们有某种神经系统症状。而“炮弹休克”一词则于1915年2月在医学期刊《柳叶刀》的一篇文章中被首次创造出来，
by Captain Charles S. Myers, the Royal Army Medical Corps. And I had to look at it. You can see it online. And Myers is writing about three cases of soldiers. who have had shells explode nearby, and these soldiers ever since have had blurred vision, they've been shivering, they have been crying, they've been in a state of general confusion,
由英国皇家陆军医疗队的查尔斯·S·迈尔斯（Charles S. Myers）上尉提出。我曾查阅过它。你可以在网上看到。迈尔斯在文中写到了三名士兵的病例。这些士兵附近曾有炮弹爆炸，自那以后，他们一直视力模糊、浑身发抖、一直在哭泣，处于一种普遍的混乱状态，
and the doctors cannot see an obvious physical cause for it. So, Dominic, the stereotype is that the British High Command regard this as nonsense and think that the chaps should man up. Is that actually the case, or is it a little bit more nuanced, I'm guessing the latter? It is more nuanced. So this is part of the sort of caricature. I mean, you alluded to it in the first half, that the generals with their tremendous moustaches,
而医生们却找不到明显的生理原因。那么，多米尼克，有一种刻板印象认为英国最高指挥部认为这全是无稽之谈，并认为这些小伙子们应该振作起来。实际情况确实如此，还是说它更微妙一些？我猜是后者。情况确实更微妙。所以这也是某种讽刺漫画的一部分。我的意思是，你在前半部分也暗示过这一点，那些留着惊人大胡子的将军们，
are sitting in castles, kind of eating elaborate meals, and just throwing their men into the meat grinder, into the meat grinder, heedlessly, and that they are incredibly reactionary and stupid, that they are donkeys, leading lions, and all of this. So the figure that you often see, the fact that people often bring up,
坐在城堡里，吃着精致的饭菜，只是毫不顾忌地把他们的人民扔进绞肉机、扔进绞肉机，而且他们极其反动、愚蠢，他们是率领雄狮的蠢驴，诸如此类。所以你经常看到的那个说法，人们经常提起的现象，
they say a lot of men were executed, for desertion and cowardice when really they were suffering from shell shock. So 306 British and imperial soldiers were executed for cowardice, 650 Frenchmen, and actually, interestingly, only 48 Germans.
他们说许多人因为逃兵和懦弱而被处决，而实际上他们患的是炮弹休克。因此，有306名英国及帝国士兵因懦弱被处决，650名法国人，而且有趣的是，德国人只有48人。
So it differs from army to army. Actually, the Italians are the worst. They're very harsh on their own men. But these figures, as, you know, lamentable as they are, they're a tiny, tiny fraction. Right, because we're talking about millions. of competence. Right. So there were six million British Empire troops. And of those, only 306
所以不同军队的情况有所不同。实际上，意大利人是最糟糕的。他们对自己人非常严厉。但这些数字，正如你所知，尽管令人痛心，却只是极小极小的一部分。没错，因为我们谈论的是数以百万计的参战人员。没错。因此，大英帝国军队有六百万。其中只有306人
are executed for cowardice. I mean, that's 306 too many, you might say, but it's still not that many. And actually, what that might suggest is the authorities are more nuanced and more sensitive to this than you might assume. And in fact, they are, because in May 1915, the war office sent a doctor to the front, Dr. Aldrin Turner, and they said to him, investigate this new disorder. And Turner wrote back, he wrote his report, he said, It's not just cowardice. It is a form of temporary nervous breakdown, often after soldiers have witnessed a ghastly sight or a harassing experience.
因懦弱而被处决。我的意思是，你可能会说306人已经太多了，但它其实并没有那么多。实际上，这可能表明当局比你想象的要更微妙、更敏感。事实上也确实如此，因为在1915年5月，战争部派了一名医生奥尔德林·特纳（Aldrin Turner）博士去前线，他们对他说，去调查这种新疾病。特纳回信写了他的报告，他说，这不仅仅是懦弱。这是一种短暂的神经崩溃形式，通常发生在士兵目睹了可怕的景象或经历痛苦的体验之后。
The patient becomes nervy and duly emotional and shaky, and most typical of all, his sleep is disturbed by bad dreams. And actually, we already mentioned Wilfred Owen, the strange meeting poem, Bad dreams are a feature of a lot of war poetry. This is following on from an episode we did on the Battle of Marathon. and there is an account in Herodotus of someone at the Battle of Marathon who gets what is often described as shell-shock, it's often described as the first instance in recorded history of this condition.
患者变得神经过敏、情绪异常且浑身发抖，最典型的特征是，他的睡眠被噩梦打扰。事实上，我们之前已经提到了威尔弗雷德·欧文（Wilfred Owen）的那首《奇异的相遇》（Strange Meeting）这首诗，噩梦是许多战争诗歌的一个特征。这是在我们做过的一期关于马拉松战役的节目之后延续下来的。希罗多德（Herodotus）的记述中提到了马拉松战役中的某个人，他得了通常被称为“炮弹休克”的病，这通常被描述为有史以来该病症的第一例。
Yeah, surely it must have, I mean, there must have been men at Waterloo who were completely traumatised or the Crimea or something. I mean, it's utterly implausible that there weren't, or indeed Ashinko, frankly. Some of these battles must have been terrifying experiences that recurred in men's dreams for years or for decades, afterwards. Yeah, the soldier at Marathon sees a kind of colossal figure moving through the ranks and he ends up blind from the shock of it. Well, so what the war office experts can't agree on is whether the cause is mental or physical. And back in Britain, they set up at least 20
是的，这肯定发生过，我的意思是，滑铁卢战役或克里米亚战役中肯定有完全遭受创伤的人。我的意思是，说没有这是绝对难以置信的，坦白说，甚至在阿琴库尔也是如此。其中一些战役肯定是可怕的经历，会在人们的梦中重现数年甚至数十年。是的，马拉松战役中的那名士兵看到一个巨大的身影在军队中移动，最后他被吓得双目失明。好吧，战争部专家们无法达成共识的是，其起因究竟是精神上的还是生理上的。回到英国，他们建立了至少20个
specialist hospitals to treat what is then called neurasthenia. And the most famous of these is Craig Lockhart in Edinburgh. This is the hospital in Pat Barker's Regeneration Trilogy. And And this is where Secreid Sassoon meets Wilfred Owen in due course. The two great poets meet each other. Now, senior officers think it's, you know, they think it's a real thing, Shellshock, but often they say, well, it's maybe the result of an individual weakness, that you have a flaw in your temperament. But actually, most of the men we've mentioned in this episode prove that to be totally wrong.
专业医院来治疗当时被称为神经衰弱（neurasthenia）的疾病。其中最著名的是爱丁堡的克雷格洛克哈特（Craiglockhart）。这就是帕特·巴克（Pat Barker）的《再生三部曲》（Regeneration Trilogy）中的那家医院。而这也是西格弗里德·萨松在适时候见到了威尔弗雷德·欧文的地方。这两位伟大的诗人在那里相遇了。现在，高级军官们认为这确实存在，也就是炮弹休克，但他们经常说，这也许是个体软弱的结果，说明你的性格有缺陷。但事实上，我们在本期节目中提到的绝大多数人都证明了这一点完全是错误的。
So we mentioned Ernst Junger. Ernst Junger is ridiculously brave, and he also loves war. But he describes in Storm of Steel. how there's a point where he becomes so jumpy that when somebody drops a book in the dugout, he'll be reduced to being a gibbering wreck because he thinks it's a landing shell. There's a moment in the book
所以我们提到了恩斯特·容格（Ernst Junger）。恩斯特·容格极其勇敢，而且他也很热爱战争。但他在《钢铁风暴》（Storm of Steel）中描述了这样一个时刻：他变得非常神经质，以至于当有人在防空洞里掉落一本书时，他会被吓得魂飞魄散、语无伦次，因为他以为那是一颗落下的炮弹。书中有这样一个时刻
where he and his men come under heavy shell fire and he runs away in terror and then he meets up with some of the survivors. And I quote, I was finished. I threw myself on the ground and I broke into convulsive sobs while the men stood gloomily around me.
他和他的部下遭到猛烈炮击，他吓得逃跑了，然后他与一些幸存者汇合。我引用他的话：“我完了。我把自己摔倒在地，爆发出痉挛般的抽泣，而士兵们阴沉地站在我周围。”
This is a very brave and militaristic man doing this. Siegfried Sassoon. so suicidally brave that his men nicknamed him Mad Jack wins the military cross and then he cracks he publishes this denunciation of the war he's sent to this hospital and then when he's been in the hospital
这是一个非常勇敢且具有军国主义色彩的人做出的举动。西格弗雷德·萨松勇敢到近乎自杀，他的部下给他起了个绰号叫“疯狂杰克”（Mad Jack），他获得了军功十字勋章，然后他崩溃了，他发表了对这场战争的谴责，他被送进了这家医院，然后当他呆在医院里之后，
he comes out of the hospital and he goes back to the front and he fights very bravely again so you know everybody has their kind of breaking point Robert Graves in goodbye to all that he says everyone has a breaking point and the way it works is this you've been there a month and you start to show the first signs of shell
他离开了医院，重返前线，并再次非常勇敢地战斗。所以你知道，每个人都有其崩溃的边缘。罗伯特·格雷夫斯在《告别这一切》（Goodbye to All That）中说，每个人都有崩溃的边缘，它的运作方式是这样的：你在那里待了一个月，你开始表现出第一批炮弹休克的迹象。
shock. After nine months, an officer becomes a drag on the other company officers. After 12 months, an officer is, and I quote, worse than useless. And by the summer of 1916, by which point he's been there 12 months, he can feel it in himself. Quote, my breaking point was near now. It would be a general nervous collapse with tears and twitchings and dirtied trousers. I had seen cases like that. But as it happens, he's wounded by a shell fragment of the Somme. He almost dies and he's invalided out and he never comes back. And at that point, he definitely has what we would call shell shock. The fear of gas obsessed me, any unusual smell, even a sudden strong scent of flowers in a garden was enough to send me trembling. And I couldn't face the
九个月后，一名军官就会成为连队其他军官的拖累。十二个月后，一名军官，我引述他的话，“比废物还不如”。到了1916年夏天，当时他在那里已经待了12个月了，他自己也能感觉到这一点。引述：“我的崩溃边缘现在已经临近了。那将是一次全面的神经崩溃，伴随着眼泪、抽搐和弄脏的裤子。我见过这样的病例。”但碰巧的是，他在索姆河被一块炮弹碎片炸伤。他差点死掉，随后被遣送回国，再也没有回来。在那一刻，他绝对得了我们所说的炮弹休克。对毒气的恐惧困扰着我，任何不寻常的气味，甚至花园里突然飘来的浓郁花香，都足以让我浑身发抖。我无法面对
sound of heavy shelling now. The noise of a car backfiring would send me flat on my face or running for cover. Do the military authorities start to factor this in? I mean, do they start to think, well, after a year or two, soldiers are going to be useless, or do they just carry on anyway? Good question. I think they're aware of it, but I think the demands of manpower are so great. People always have this idea, I think, of the First World War generals. It's just this sort of boorish, brutal idiots. But actually, when you look at their life stories and their lives away from the war, often these quite cultivated, intelligent kind of men, the truth is they are in an impossible situation, and they're so, there's this urgent demand for men at the front.
现在重炮轰鸣的声音。汽车回火的声音会让我吓得趴在地上或跑去寻找掩护。军方当局开始将这一点考虑进去了吗？我的意思是，他们是否开始认为，一两年后，士兵们就会变成废人，或者他们只是不管怎样继续硬撑？好问题。我想他们意识到了这一点，但我认为人力需求太大了。人们对第一次世界大战的将军们总是有这样一种看法：他们只是一群粗鲁、残酷的笨蛋。但实际上，当你审视他们的生平故事以及他们离开战争的生活时，这些往往是相当有教养、聪明的人，事实是他们处于一种不可能的境地，而且前线对人力的需求是如此迫切。
So they can't give everybody a break every now and again. And it's what we were saying right at the start, that they are facing a situation, a strategic situation, that is so imponderable that they are just groping around for answers. Indeed, and this brings us perfectly to one of the first answers they come up with. So Graves just mentioned it. And this is the secret weapon that the Germans come up with in the early months. of 1915 to try to break this deadlock.
所以他们无法时不时地让每个人都休息一下。这就是我们一开始所说的，他们面临着一种战略形势，这种形势是如此难以捉摸，以至于他们只能在黑暗中摸索答案。确实如此，这也完美地引出了他们想出的最早的答案之一。格雷夫斯刚刚提到了这一点。这就是德国人在1915年初为了打破这种僵局而秘密研制的武器。
And this is gas. Now, both sides had experimented with gas before the war, but the Germans had a massive head start because they're a big scientific powerhouse, the biggest in the world. They have the best researchers, they have the best chemical engineers, they have manufacturers like Agfa and Bayer
这就是毒气。现在，战争爆发前双方都曾试验过毒气，但德国人占据了巨大的领先优势，因为他们是一个庞大的科研大国，是世界上最大的科研大国。他们拥有最好的研究人员，最好的化学工程师，他们拥有诸如爱克发（Agfa）和拜耳（Bayer）
and all these kind of companies. I mean, this is maybe, but it's still cheating, isn't it? I mean, it's not cricket. I don't think it is cheating, actually, because the Hay Convention of 1899 outlawed using projectiles that would be solely used for asphyxating or deleterious gases
以及所有这类公司。我的意思是，这也许……但这仍然是作弊，不是吗？我的意思是，这不符合板球精神（不光明磊落）。我认为这其实不算作弊，因为1899年的海牙公约取缔了专门用于窒息或有害气体的弹丸的使用，
but the Germans get their lawyers to look at this and the lawyers say, as long as you're not using projectiles that have been made solely for that purpose, nothing else has been outlawed. And their new Supreme Commander Eric von Falkenheim, kind of Prussian figure,
但德国人的律师研究了这一点，律师们说，只要你们使用的不是专为此目的制造而别的用途都没有的弹丸，其他东西就没有被取缔。他们的最高新指挥官埃里希·冯·法金汉（Eric von Falkenhyn），一个颇具普鲁士风格的人物，
he says, look, we're going to lose if it's a long war. I mean, they know that. the Germans, and their great gamble has failed. We must try anything urgently to get a breakthrough. I mean, he has the vibe of a man who would approve of mustard gas. That's harsh. That's harsh. That's harsh. The name, the look. I mean, to be fair, the British ended up using gas too. Would you say that of Douglas Haig? Or Sir John French? I would definitely have Sir John French.
他说，听着，如果这是一场持久战，我们就会输。我的意思是，德国人知道这一点，他们的大赌注已经失败了。我们必须不惜一切代价尝试任何方法来取得突破。我的意思是，他给人的感觉是一个会赞成使用芥子气的人。这话说得太严厉了。这太严厉了。这太严厉了。那个名字，那个长相。公平地说，英国人最后也使用了毒气。你会对道格拉斯·黑格（Douglas Haig）这么说吗？还是对约翰·法国爵士（Sir John French）？我绝对会把这话说给约翰·法国爵士听。
What did we call John French last time? Paltroon and a buffoon, I think, wasn't it? Anyway, lots of Falcon Heinz officers say to him, I don't know about this. First of all, the Allies will retaliate with gas themselves. And the prevailing winds over France and Flanders... Right. Are westerly. Yeah, they're in the wrong direction. We'll be in a mess.
我们上次是怎么称呼约翰·法国的？懦夫和丑角，我想，不是吗？无论如何，法金汉的许多军官对他说，我对此并不确定。首先，盟军自己也会用毒气进行报复。而且法国和法兰德斯上空的盛行风向……没错。是西风。是的，风向不对。我们会陷入困境的。
But also, some people definitely agree with you, Tom. So somebody who agrees with you is General Karl von Einem of the Third Army. And he wrote to his wife, I fear it will produce a tremendous scandal in the world. War has nothing to do with chivalry anymore. The higher civilization rises, the vilerman. becomes. So he's not an enthusiast for gas. Even so, they decide to go for it and they're going to launch it on the 22nd of April at Eapr. Now people may remember, there's a thing called the Eepr salient,
但同时，有些人绝对同意你的看法，汤姆。所以一个同意你观点的人是第三集团军的卡尔·冯·艾内姆（Karl von Einem）将军。他写信给妻子：“我担心这会在世界上引起轩然大波。战争与骑士精神再无关系。文明程度越高，人就越邪恶。”所以他不是毒气的狂热爱好者。即便如此，他们还是决定孤注一掷，并准备在4月22日在伊普尔（Ypres）发动毒气战。现在人们可能还记得，有一个地方叫做伊普尔突出部（Ypres salient），
which is basically the front line bulges out a bit. So it's sort of surrounded on three sides, and the British are determined to hold it, and this is where the Germans are going to make their trial. And at 5 o'clock that evening, the engineers opened the valves on 6,000 cylinders of chlorine gas. They're waiting for the wind to be in the right direction. The wind blows this yellow kind of cloud towards thousands of actually French Algerian troops who are the people in the way.
基本上就是前线向外凸出了一点。所以它三面受敌，而英国人决心坚守这里，这就是德国人要进行试验的地方。那天晚上5点，工程兵打开了6000个氯气钢瓶的阀门。他们在等待风向正确。风把这种黄色云团吹向了实际上挡路的成千上万名法属阿尔及利亚士兵。
And these Algerian blokes flee in total panic. They're blinded. They're screaming for water. They're vomiting blood as the gas is basically eating into their lungs. Now, as it turns out, even though this opens a hole in the Allied lines, the Germans don't have enough reserves to exploit it properly. Two days later, they have another go, more gas.
这些阿尔及利亚士兵陷入完全的恐慌中，四散逃窜。他们被熏瞎了眼。他们尖叫着要水喝。随着毒气基本上在吞噬他们的肺部，他们呕吐出鲜血。现在事实证明，尽管这在盟军防线上撕开了一个缺口，但德国人没有足够的预备队来好好利用它。两天后，他们又来了一次，释放了更多的毒气。
This time they are targeting Canadian And again, the gas inspires utter horror and panic. So this is one of many sort of awful eye witness accounts. I've never seen men so terror-stricken. They were tearing at their throats. Their eyes were glaring out. Blood was streaming from those who were wounded and they were tumbling over each other. Those who fell couldn't get up because of the panic of the men following them.
这一次他们的目标是加拿大人。同样，毒气激发了彻底的恐惧和恐慌。所以这是众多可怕的目击者记述之一。我从未见过如此惊恐万状的人。他们拼命抓着自己的喉咙。他们的眼睛瞪得极大。鲜血从受伤的人身上涌出，他们一个接一个地跌倒在一起。那些摔倒的人因为后面人的恐慌而无法站起来。
And eventually they were piled up two or three high in the trench. And it's this that's the context for the poem that we began with in Flanders Fields. So it's against this background that McCrae writes those famous words. And he was from Ontario, rural Ontario. He was a very distinguished doctor and a professor of pathology. He had volunteered in the Burr War. So he loved Britain. I applaud him.
最终，战壕里堆起了两三层高的人。而这正是我们一开始提到的那首诗《在法兰德斯战场》（In Flanders Fields）的背景。所以麦克雷正是在这种背景下写下了那些著名的词句。他来自安大略省，安大略省的乡村。他是一位非常杰出的医生和病理学教授。他曾自愿参加布尔战争。所以他深爱英国。我为他鼓掌。
He volunteered again in 1914, even though he was 41. And he became the chief medical officer of the first brigade of the Canadian field artillery. So he's in the thick of all this. And on the 2nd of May, a friend of his who was called Lieutenant Alexis Helmer was killed by a shell and McCray presided over his burial service and it's at that point at his burial service that McCray noticed these poppies growing around the grave and the next day I mean there are multiple different kind of apocryphal stories about this but the most common is McCray is sitting in the back of an ambulance near Eap and he's just thinking about these poppies
他在1914年再次自愿参战，尽管他当时已经41岁了。他成为了加拿大野战炮兵第一旅的首席医疗官。所以他身处这一切的核心。5月2日，他的一位名叫亚历克西斯·赫尔默（Alexis Helmer）中尉的朋友被一颗炮弹炸死，麦克雷主持了他的葬礼，正是在他的葬礼上，麦克雷注意到坟墓周围长出了这些罂粟花，第二天——我的意思是，关于这一点有多种不同的虚构传说，但最常见的是麦克雷坐在伊普尔附近的一辆救护车的后面，他脑子里正想着这些罂粟花，
and he scribbles this poem in his notepad and then the story goes that he read he read it to some of the other guys. And then he crumpled it up and threw it away. And one of the other guys picked it up and said, don't throw it away. It's actually good. He ended up sending it to the humorous magazine Punch, where it was published in December 1915. And it was a massive hit. And it was used in British propaganda, in Canadian, in American propaganda. In Canada in particular, it became a real kind of sensation. McCrae himself, unfortunately, died in the last year of the war. He of pneumonia and meningitis. But the poem, as we said right at the beginning,
然后他在记事本上草草写下了这首诗，接着传说他把这首诗读给其他几个小伙子听。然后他把它揉成一团扔掉了。其中一个小伙子把它捡起来说，别扔掉。这其实挺不错的。他最终把它寄给了幽默杂志《Punch》（笨拙杂志），并于1915年12月发表。它大获成功。它被用在了英国宣传、加拿大宣传、美国宣传中。特别是在加拿大，它真正成了一种轰动全国的现象。不幸的是，麦克雷本人在战争的最后一年去世了。他死于肺炎和脑膜炎。但这首诗，正如我们在最开始所说的那样，
lives on, well, it lives on, I mean, it's quoted every November, isn't it, in Britain, certainly, probably in Canada too, I imagine. Anyway, back to the gas. Gas is one of a series of innovations, so massive artillery bombardments, I suppose, U-boats, tanks, all of these things that haven't really been seen before. But gas is the one that frightens soldiers the most, because it's this silent killer, invisible killer. You know, you don't see it coming, and as soon as it's on you, you're dead.
流传了下来，嗯，它流传了下来，我的意思是，每年11月都会被引用，不是吗？在英国肯定如此，我想在加拿大大概也是如此。无论如何，回到毒气。毒气是一系列创新之一，所以我想大规模的炮击、潜艇、坦克，所有这些以前从未真正见过的东西。但毒气是最让士兵们感到害怕的东西，因为它是无声的杀手，隐形的杀手。你知道，你根本看不到它来，一旦它落到你身上，你就没命了。
Though that one that attacks the French Algerian troops, it's yellowish. It was yellowish, so I say it's invisible. I mean, you might not, would you notice a yellowish vapour heading towards you? I think I probably would. Okay, well, fair. There's a brilliant description by the fighter ace, Cecil Lewis. He watched it from above, and he said he watched it, creeping panther-like over the scarred earth, curling down into dugouts,
虽然攻击法属阿尔及利亚士兵的那种是黄色的。它是黄色的，所以我说它是隐形的。我的意思是，你可能不会，你会注意到一股黄色的蒸气朝你飘来吗？我想我大概会。好吧，那好吧。战斗机王牌塞西尔·刘易斯（Cecil Lewis）有一段精彩的描述。他从高处俯瞰，他说他看着它，像美洲豹一样在伤痕累累的大地上匍匐前进，蜿蜒卷入防空洞，
coiling and uncoiling at the wind's whim. Men were dying there under me from a whiff of it, not dying quickly, not even maimed or shattered, but dying whole, retching and vomiting blood and guts, and those who lived would be wrecks with seared, poison lungs, rotten for life. Because that is one of the archetypes of the Great War, isn't it? I mean, that's one of the reasons why it lives with such a kind of tamber of horror in people's memories.
随风意盘绕又伸展。人们就在我脚下的毒气中死去，不是死得痛快，甚至没有残疾或粉身碎骨，而是全尸而亡，作呕并吐出鲜血和内脏，而那些活下来的人将成为残废，肺部被灼伤、毒化，终生溃烂。因为这是第一次世界大战的典型特征之一，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是为什么它在人们的记忆中带着那种恐怖的氛围挥之不去的原因。
And it's the theme of perhaps the most famous poem written about the horrors of the war. Yeah, Wilfred Owens, Dulcea de Coromest, where there's a line in that poem where there's a gas boys, gas, or whatever it is, and they're all rushing to get their masks on. There's one guy who's been too slow,
这也是也许是关于战争恐怖的最著名诗歌的主题。是的，威尔弗雷德·欧文的《杜勒斯·埃·德科鲁姆·埃斯蒂》（Dulce et Decorum est），这首诗里有一行写道，有毒气，伙计们，毒气，或者诸如此类的话，然后他们都急忙戴上防空面具。有一个家伙动作太慢了，
and the imagery is all green, dim through the misty panes and thick green light, as under a green sea I saw him drowning. In all his dreams before my helpless sight, he plunges at me, guttering, choking, drowning. So it's horrible. but does it work? No, this is a waste of time.
其意象全都是绿色，透过朦胧的镜片显得昏暗，笼罩在浓绿的灯光下，就像在绿色的大海中我看到他在溺水。在他所有的梦中，在我无助的视线前，他向我扑来，气喘吁吁、窒息、溺水。所以这太可怕了。但它管用吗？不，这是在浪费时间。
Totally waste of time. So there's no breakthrough at EAP. The Canadians hold firm. And the thing is, the gas doesn't kill enough people. I mean, that sounds like a mad thing to say. But only 6,000 British and Imperial forces and the whole course of the war died of gas poisoning. I'd assumed it was much more than that.
完全是在浪费时间。所以伊普尔没有取得突破。加拿大人坚守阵地。关键是，毒气并没有杀死足够多的人。我的意思是，这听起来像是疯了才说的话。但在整个战争期间，只有6000名英国及帝国军队死于毒气中毒。我本以为远不止这个数字。
No, it doesn't kill you, by and large. Just leaves you with ruined lungs. Yeah, it definitely leaves people with ruined lungs. No question. I mean, part of that is because the war office were quite good in getting gas masks to the front. So the first gas masks arrived a few weeks later. And these are sort of gauze pads that you tie over your face a little bit like, I suppose, like a COVID mask. I mean, up to that point, they basically were saying, you know, you need to urinate on some cloth and hold it over your face and the urine will act as a.
不，它基本上不会致死。只会给你的肺部留下毁坏。是的，它绝对给人们留下了残破的肺，毫无疑问。我的意思是，部分原因是因为战争部在将防空面具运送到前线方面做得相当不错。所以第一批防空面具几周后就运到了。这些是绑在脸上的纱布垫，有点像，我想，就像新冠口罩。我的意思是，在那之前，他们基本上是在说，你知道，你需要在一些布料上小便，然后把它捂在脸上，尿液会起到……
And people were doing this. I mean, this is what they had, this is what they did. And then in 1960s, they issued what was called a small box respirator. that protects you against chlorine and fostein, which are the two common gases that are being used at this point. The one thing it doesn't protect you against is mustard gas, because mustard gas blisters your skin. So you know the famous painting by John Singer-Sargent?
人们当时确实在这么做。我的意思是，这就是他们拥有的，这就是他们所做的。然后在1916年，他们发放了所谓的小箱式呼吸器。它能保护你免受氯气和光气（fostein）的伤害，这是当时使用的两种常见气体。它唯一不能保护你的是芥子气，因为芥子气会使你的皮肤起水泡。所以你知道约翰·辛格·萨金特（John Singer-Sargent）的那幅著名油画吗？
Oh, the one where they're all in a line. They're all in a line. That's mustard gas that they are suffering from, not chlorine. Now, you said it wasn't cricket. Sir John French, the well-known Paltroon, he agrees with you, the commander of the British Expeditionary Force. Oh, I maligned him then. I take it all back. Right. Okay. He said it was a cynical and barbarous disregard of the well-known usages of civilized war.
哦，就是他们排成一长排的那幅。他们排成了一长排。他们遭受的是芥子气，而不是氯气。现在，你刚才说这不符合板球精神。约翰·法国爵士，那位著名的懦夫，他同意你的观点，英国远征军的指挥官。哦，那我当时是在诋毁他了。我收回刚才的话。好吧。好吧。他说这是对文明战争既定惯例的“冷酷而野蛮的无视”。
And of course, the Allied newspapers say, well, this is typical of the Germans. This is how the Germans behave. They're Huns, they're barbarians. I mean, I think it's probably fairer to say, if you're losing, if you're the underdog, you will try anything. And this is what the Germans are doing. Especially if you've got a massive world-beaten chemicals industry. Yeah. I mean, they'd be kind of, I mean, I don't want to sound too pro-tuton. But yet they'd be mad not to try it, I think. Anyway, the British, for all their talk of it not being cricket, they are secretly testing gas weapons themselves. And they make the same mistake the Germans did. They sort of convinced themselves, this will be brilliant.
当然，盟军报纸会说，这正是德国人的典型表现。德国人就是这样行事的。他们是匈奴人，是野蛮人群。我的意思是，我想更公道地说，如果你正在输掉战争，如果你是处于劣势的一方，你就会尝试任何方法。这就是德国人正在做的事情。特别是如果你拥有庞大且世界顶级的化学工业的话。是的。我的意思是，他们会，我不想听起来太亲日耳曼。但他们如果不去尝试，那才叫疯了呢。无论如何，英国人在高谈阔论这不符合板球精神的同时，他们自己也在秘密测试毒气武器。他们犯了和德国人一样的错误。他们某种程度上说服了自己，这将会非常棒。
This will actually be a game changer. And so this sets the stage for the biggest British attack of the whole of the year, 1915. It's in Luce, which is just south of Lille in France. Sometimes, Tom, you hear people saying that Luce might be in Belgium, but it's not, is it? No. I mean, that's a rookie's error, isn't it? Anyone who thinks that is mad. So people who enjoy British shambolic British military failures will relish the beginning of the Battle of Luce.
这实际上会是一个游戏规则的改变者。这就为1915年全年英国最大规模的进攻拉开了序幕。地点在卢斯（Loos），就在法国里尔（Lille）的正南方。有时候，汤姆，你会听到人们说卢斯可能在比利时，但其实不在，对吧？不。我的意思是，这是一个菜鸟级的错误，不是吗？任何认为那是比利时的人都疯了。所以喜欢英国混乱军事失败的人一定会津津乐道地回顾卢斯战役的开端。
The British have planned this gas bombardment. They've got 5,000 cylinders of chlorine gas. At 6 o'clock in the morning, they prepare to unleash them. And the gas engineers say, the wind is in the wrong way. Don't open these gas cylinders, whatever you do. Are the top brass going to pay attention to this? The top brass say, no, it's too late to change the plan now. Are you mad?
英国人策划了这次毒气轰炸。他们准备了5000个氯气钢瓶。早上6点，他们准备释放毒气。而毒气工程兵说，风向不对。千万不要打开这些毒气钢瓶，无论如何都不要。高级将领会理睬这个吗？高级将领说，不，现在改变计划太晚了。你疯了吗？
Carry on. So they basically open the gas cylinders and it all blows back in their faces. And they've got these flannel gas masks. With urine. No, I don't think they've got urine. I think it's some sort of chemical treatment or whatever. Anyway, they've got these gas masks. The eyepieces of the gas masks steam up.
继续执行。所以他们基本上打开了毒气钢瓶，毒气全都被吹回了他们的脸上。他们戴着那种法兰绒防空面具。用尿液。不，我想他们没有用尿液。我想那是某种化学处理还是别的什么。无论如何，他们戴上了防空面具。防空面具的镜片上起满了雾气。
So the men, to see, take the gas mask off. They probably are poisoned by their own gas. So it's basically like that poor bloke who throws the missile out and then it blows up in his face. Yeah, it's basically that on a huge scale. because basically the British gas gasped four times, caused four times as many casualties among the British as it did among the Germans. Anyway, when they finally ordered the troops to advance,
所以为了能看清，士兵们摘下了防空面具。他们很可能被自己的毒气毒死了。所以这基本上就像那个可怜的家伙扔出导弹，结果导弹在自己脸前爆炸了一样。是的，基本上就是大号的这种版本。因为基本上英国毒气造成的伤亡人数是英国人自己的四倍，而在德国人中间造成的伤亡却没那么多。无论如何，当他们最终下令部队向前推进时，
they find the Germans very much ungassed. And their artillery bombardment, and this is a theme that will run for the next few years, their artillery and bombardment, which they thought will break the German barbed wire and weaken their defences, has completely failed to do so. So basically, loose, which goes on for the next two weeks,
他们发现德国人根本没有被毒气熏倒。而他们的炮击——这将是未来几年一直延续的一个主题——他们本以为炮击会摧毁德国的铁丝网并削弱他们的防御，结果却完全未能做到这一点。所以基本上，持续了接下来的两周的卢斯战役，
is your classic example of a Western Front offensive, where generals are throwing men against positions that turn out to be a much better defendant than they thought, and they're getting absolutely nowhere. It ends with 60,000 British casualties, only 25,000 German casualties. It is one of the great Allied disasters of the first year or so of the war. And the result of this is that finally Sir John French, who has been useless, frankly, from the very beginning. And if you remember, he actually wanted to abandon the French completely. he's finally booted out as commander-in-chief
是西线进攻的典型例子，将军们把士兵们投入到那些防守远比他们想象的要好的阵地中，结果却一无所获。战役以英国伤亡60,000人、德国伤亡仅25,000人告终。这是战争头一年左右盟军最大的灾难之一。其结果是，约翰·法国爵士终于被解职了，坦白说他从一开始就一无是处。如果你还记得的话，他实际上想彻底抛弃法国人。他最终被总司令的宝座上踢了出去，
and he's replaced with Sir Douglas Hague. And French is the guy who the British government thinks is just the man to go and solve the Irish question in due call. Yes. Where he's another tremendous success. Poor Sir John French. Surely at some point we'll have to do a whole series rehabilitating him. But anyway, he's been replaced by Douglas Hague,
取而代之的是道格拉斯·黑格爵士（Sir Douglas Haig）。而法国爵士就是那个英国政府认为恰好可以去适时解决爱尔兰问题的人。是的。他在那里取得了又一次巨大的成功。可怜的约翰·法国爵士。总有一天我们得做一整个系列来为他平反。不过无论如何，他被道格拉斯·黑格取代了，
one of the most controversial characters in British and indeed all military history. The goody, baddie? I think we should come to this later on when I've read a bit more about it, because actually I don't know what I think. I think probably he's been a bit. The general sense now is that he was maligned.
道格拉斯·黑格是英国乃至整个军事史上最具争议的人物之一。好人还是坏人？我想我们应该稍后当我读了更多相关资料时再来讨论这一点，因为实际上我不知道自己是怎么想的。我想他可能被某种程度上……现在的普遍共识是，他受到了恶意的诋毁。
Gary Sheffield, he's all over. How good Douglas Haynes. From the University of Wolverhampton thinks that Douglas Hager is one of the greatest men who ever lived, I think. Well, there you go. Anyway, just to end the episode. 60,000 British casualties at loose, but one of them above all is very well known.
加里·谢菲尔德（Gary Sheffield），他无处不在。来自伍尔弗汉普顿大学的道格拉斯·黑格有多优秀？他认为道格拉斯·黑格是有史以来最伟大的人物之一，我想。好吧，那就这样吧。无论如何，就用这个来结束本期节目。卢斯战役中有6万名英国伤亡人员，但其中有一个人格外知名。
And this is a young man who was 18 years old called John Kipling. And he was the only son of Rudyard Kipling, the great poet of empire and indeed of patriotism. John Kipling was 16 years old when the war broke out and his father was desperate to get him a commission. But John was rejected because of severe short-sightedness. Basically, the medical board said he would be totally at sea because he can't see anything.
这是一个18岁的年轻小伙子，名叫约翰·吉卜林（John Kipling）。他是鲁德亚德·吉卜林（Rudyard Kipling）的独生子，后者是伟大的帝国诗人和爱国主义诗人。战争爆发时，约翰·吉卜林16岁，他的父亲极力想为他谋取一个军官职位。但约翰因为严重近视而被拒绝。基本上，医疗委员会说他将会完全不知所措，因为他什么也看不见。
But Kipling Sr. pulled all kinds of strings with his old friend Lord Roberts and he got John commissioned as a second lieutenant in the Irish Guards. And on the second day of the Battle of Luce, John Kipling was reported missing in action. And he was, and I quote, last scene, stumbling in the mud in search of his glasses, which had fallen off during the attack. And Rudyard Kipling was devastated by this.
但老吉卜林通过他的老朋友罗伯茨勋爵（Lord Roberts）拉拢了各种关系，让约翰被任命为爱尔兰卫队（Irish Guards）的少尉。在卢斯战役的第二天，约翰·吉卜林被报告在行动中失踪。据引述，他“最后一次被看到是在泥泞中跌跌撞撞地寻找他的眼镜，他的眼镜在进攻时掉了下来”。鲁德亚德·吉卜林对此痛不欲生。
He never recovered. And when he published his epitaphs for the war in 1919, the theme of dead sons and bereaved parents runs right through it. And the most famous of all these epitaphs that Kipling wrote is a couplet that's often seen as an epitaph for the war more generally. If any question why we died, tell them because our fathers lied. And it's not generally thought of, is it, that Kipling wrote perhaps the most devastating couplet condemning the war of any poet. Exactly. And of course, we've talked before in the show about his short story, The Gardner, which I think is one of the most moving short stories ever written, which is also about the loss of a young man in action. Right. There'll be a lot more young men to be lost, sadly, because there are five more episodes to come in this dramatic series.
他再也没有恢复过来。当他在1919年出版他的战争墓志铭时，阵亡儿子和痛失亲人的父母这一主题贯穿始终。吉卜林写的所有墓志铭中最著名的是一个对联，它经常被视为对整场战争的墓志铭：“如果有任何人问我们为何牺牲，告诉他们：因为我们的父辈撒了谎。”人们通常不会想到，吉卜林写出了所有诗人中也许最具毁灭性的、谴责战争的一联。完全正确。当然，我们在节目中之前讨论过他的短篇小说《园丁》（The Gardner），我认为这是有史以来最感人的短篇小说之一，它也是关于在行动中失去年轻生命的。没错。可悲的是，还会有更多的年轻生命消逝，因为在这个戏剧性的系列中还有五集要播出。
All of them set over the course of this one tumultuous year, 1915. So next time, a new combatant enters the arena. This is Italy. We tell the story of how Italy, we tell the story of how Italy, was cajoled into war by the proto-fascist poet Gabrile Donuccio and of the dreadful fate that awaited the Italians when they went up into the mountains to fight the Austro-Hungarian army. Then next week, two of the great controversial stories of the wars, that's the sinking of the lucetania by a German U-boat and the execution of the British nurse and alleged spy Edith Cavill. And then in the third week, finally, we get to one of the great military disasters in all history. And that is the Allied attempt to land at Gallipoli.
所有这些都设定在这个动荡的年份1915年。所以下一次，一个新的参战者将进入竞技场。这就是意大利。我们将讲述意大利的故事，我们讲述意大利是如何被准法西斯诗人加布里埃尔·邓邓齐奥（Gabriele D'Annunzio）哄骗加入战争的，以及当意大利人登上高山与奥匈帝国军队作战时等待他们的悲惨命运。接着下周，将是战争中两个最具争议的故事，那就是德国U型潜艇击沉卢西塔尼亚号（Lusitania），以及英国护士兼据称是间谍的伊迪丝·卡韦尔（Edith Cavell）被处决。然后在第三周，最终我们将迎来整个历史上最伟大的军事灾难之一。这就是盟军在加利波利（Gallipoli）登陆的尝试。
And of course, if you're a member of the Restis History Club, you can hear those five episodes straight away. And if you go to the restishistory.com, you can join the club. And only by going to theresteshistory.com will you get the full benefits of being in the club? So lots to look forward to, Tom. Lots to look forward to. Thank you very much for that, Dominic.
当然，如果你是“历史其余部分俱乐部”（Rest is History Club）的会员，你可以立即收听这五集节目。如果你访问 therestishistory.com，就可以加入俱乐部。只有通过访问 therestishistory.com，你才能充分享受到加入俱乐部的所有福利。所以有很多值得期待的事情，汤姆。有很多值得期待的事情。非常感谢你，多米尼克。
And in our next episode, we will be. in Italy, listening to Roman rabble-rousing, and then up in the mountains of Slovenia, getting massacred by Austrians. So we'll see you then. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Hi, everybody. We are back with another absolutely colossal update about the rest is history festival. Well, it's massive. So on the 4th and 5th of July, we will be at Hampton Court Palace. We have a weekend of brilliant talks, live music, exclusive access to historic Royal Palace's collections. And yes, Dominic, most exciting, of all, this is the thing I have been pushing for, and I'm so looking forward to it. We have medieval combat, a terrifying, brutal, yet completely
在我们的下一期节目中，我们将前往意大利，聆听罗马暴民的煽动，然后前往斯洛文尼亚的山区，遭到奥地利人的大屠杀。所以我们到时见。再见。再见。大家好。我们带着关于“历史其余部分”音乐节的另一个绝对重磅的最新消息回来了。这真的是太盛大了。所以在7月4日和5日，我们将来到汉普顿宫（Hampton Court Palace）。我们将举办为期两天的精彩演讲、现场音乐，并独家参观历史悠久的皇家宫殿藏品。是的，多米尼克，最令人兴奋的是，这是我一直极力争取的事情，我太期待了。我们将有中世纪格斗，这项运动既恐怖、残酷，却又完全
thrilling sport. It is going to be an unforgettable two days. It is indeed. And at the core of the festival of these talks, we've got some more talks to add to the lineup. So I will be talking to the brilliant Tudor historian Tracy Borman about the secrets of the six wives of Henry the I'll be talking to a friend of the show and Irish National Treasure, Paul Rouse, about whether there is an alternative universe in which islands could have remained part of the United Kingdom. We'll be talking to Katya Hoyer about Weimar, Germany,
惊心动魄。这将是难忘的两天。确实如此。音乐节的核心是这些演讲，我们还将在阵容中增加更多演讲。所以我将与杰出的都铎王朝历史学家特雷西·博尔曼（Tracy Borman）交谈，探讨亨利八世六位妻子的秘密。我将与节目的朋友兼爱尔兰国宝保罗·劳斯（Paul Rouse）交谈，探讨是否存在一个平行宇宙，让爱尔兰可以留在联合王国之内。我们将与卡蒂亚·霍耶（Katya Hoyer）探讨魏玛德国，
and in particular, the town of Weimar through history, and Professor Adam Smith will be telling the story of America through three presidents. And on top of all that, I'll be doing a special event with Ian Hislaw. about the history of satire. And I will be on stage with Mary Beard and we will be talking about just how strange,
特别是历史上魏玛镇的故事，亚当·史密斯（Adam Smith）教授将通过三位总统讲述美国的故事。除此之外，我将与伊恩·希斯洛普（Ian Hislop）共同举办一场特别活动，探讨讽刺的历史。我将与玛丽·比尔德（Mary Beard）同台，我们将探讨罗马究竟有多陌生、究竟有多异类、究竟与我们有多么不同，或者也许并非如此。我将与海伦·卡斯特（Helen Castor）交谈，探讨伊丽莎白一世。我们将讨论她是否真的是英格兰最伟大的统治者，或者这个称号是否仍然应该由埃塞尔斯坦（Athelstan）来摘得。
just how alien, just how different to us Rome was, or maybe it wasn't. I will be talking to Helen Castor about Elizabeth I. And we'll be discussing whether she truly was England's greatest ruler or maybe whether that title
我将与阿里·安萨里（Ali Ansari）探讨个人的一切，与丹·杰克逊（Dan Jackson）探讨死亡深渊。我将与节目的朋友威廉·达尔林普尔（William Dalrymple）交谈，探讨古代印度与希腊和罗马之间的联系。绝对令人难以置信的盛况。
should still be claimed by Athelstan. I will be talking to Ali Ansari about all things personally, with Dan Jackson about the pit of death. And I will be talking to a friend of the show, Willie Dalrymple, about the links between ancient India and Greece and Rome. Absolutely incredible scenes.
当然，在这两天的活动中，汤姆和我都会同台进行一场联合演出。所以第一天，我们将回答所有俱乐部成员的问题。然后为了闭幕音乐节，我们将对有史以来最伟大的节目朋友进行一次终极排名。所以有很多值得
And of course, on both days, Tom and I will be on stage doing a show together as well. So on the first day, we'll be answering all our club members' questions. And then to close the festival, we will do a definitive ranking of the all-time top friends of the show. So lots to look at.
期待的。除此之外，整个周末还将发生很多很多其他事情。所以把它想象成终极的夏季历史大聚会。你的门票将为你提供完全的权限去探索汉普顿宫宏伟的都铎宫殿以及皇家网球场。所以那将非常令人兴奋。将会有适合国王的美食和饮品，听起来非常诱人。我脑海中浮现出我们俱乐部成员光鲜亮丽的身影，他们穿着夏装，在汉普顿宫的草坪上，在令人愉悦的环境中畅谈历史，啜饮着清爽的金汤力。这可能是举办过的最文明的音乐节了。我的意思是，我反正就是这么想象的。再次提醒，门票是俱乐部成员专属的。如果你还不是会员，现在正是加入的最佳
forward to. And beyond that, there is so much else that will be happening across the weekend. So think of it as the ultimate summer history hangout. And your tickets will give you full access to explore the great Tudor Palace of Hampton Court and indeed the Royal Tennis Court. So that would be very exciting. There'll be food and drink fit for a king, which sounds very enticing. I picture the very glamorous people that are our club members and their summer garb, they're on the lawn at Hampton Court Palace, they're chatting about history and delightful surroundings, sipping on a refreshing gin and tonic. And it's probably the most civilised festival there's ever been. I mean, that's what I imagine anyway. Just a reminder, the tickets are exclusive to club members. And if you are not a member, now is the perfect
时机。所以请前往 TheRestIsHistory.com 注册。并抢购门票，当然还可以享受一系列的辅助福利。一旦你注册了 TheRestIsHistory.com，你所需要做的就是登录会员区，选择音乐节，一切都非常直观。但你知道吗？还有一个转折。如果你这样做了，你将参加一个绝对令人难以置信的抽奖活动。那个抽奖活动，如果你赢了，你和另外三个人，
time to join. So head over to The Restishistory.com to sign up. And grab your tickets and of course have access to a whole range of supplementary benefits. Once you have signed up to the restishistory.com, all you do then is log into the members area and you select festival and it's all very obvious. But you know what? There is a twist. If you do this, you'll be entered into a genuinely unbelievable prize draw. And that prize draw, if you win, you and three other people, It's like the golden ticket in Charlie and the Chocolate Factory because you will be given the chance to be upgraded
就像《查理和巧克力工厂》里的金奖券一样，因为你将获得升级为高级体验的机会。高级体验将为你提供，除其他外，全天无限量的免费美食和饮品。千万不要错过。等不及要看到了。我们为什么真的要对伊拉克开战？萨达姆·侯赛因真的有大规模杀伤性武器吗？我是戈登·卡雷拉（Gordon Corera），国家安全记者。
to the premium experience. And the premium experience will give you, among other things, unlimited food and drink for free all day. Do not miss it. Can't wait to see it. Why did we really go to war with Iraq? And did Saddam Hussein really have weapons of mass destruction? I'm Gordon Carrera, National Security Journal.
我是大卫·麦克洛斯基（David McCloskey），作家兼前中情局分析师。我们是《其余皆机密》（The Rest is Classified）的主持人，在我们的最新系列节目中，我们将讲述历史最大情报失败之一的真实故事：伊拉克大规模杀伤性武器。2003年，美国和英国向世界宣称萨达姆·侯赛因拥有大规模杀伤性武器，但他们弄错了。这并非一个简单的谎言。这是一件要复杂得多、有趣得多、危险得多的事情。深信其消息来源的间谍，希望公众相信威胁的政治家，以及无法证明自己早已销毁武器的独裁者。在本系列节目中，我们将深入中情局和军情六处，进入做出决策的密室，
list. And I'm David McCloskey, author and former CIA analyst. We are the hosts of the rest is classified, and in our latest series, we are telling the true story of one of history's biggest intelligence failures, Iraq, WMD. In 2003, the U.S. and UK told the world that Saddam Hussein had weapons of mass destruction, but they were wrong. This wasn't a simple lie. It was something far more complicated, far more interesting, and far more dangerous. Spies who believed their sources, politicians who wanted the public to believe in the threat, and a dictator who couldn't prove he'd already destroyed the weapons. In this series, we go deep inside the CIA and MI6, go into the rooms where decisions were made,
名单。我是戴夫·麦克洛斯基，作家兼前中情局分析师。我们是《解密其余》（The Rest is Classified）的主持人，在我们的最新系列节目中，我们将讲述历史上最大的情报失败之一——伊拉克大规模杀伤性武器的真实故事。2003年，美英两国告诉世界萨达姆·侯赛因拥有大规模杀伤性武器，但他们错了。这并不是一个简单的谎言，而是要复杂得多、有趣得多，也危险得多。情报人员相信了他们的消息来源，政客们希望公众相信这种威胁，而一位独裁者却无法证明他已经销毁了这些武器。在这个系列中，我们将深入中情局和军情六处内部，走进那些做出决策的房间，
and look at the sources who fabricated the intelligence that took us to war. The Iraq War reshaped the Middle East and permanently weakened public trust in governments and intelligence agencies and its consequences are still playing out today. Plus, in a declassified club exclusive, we are joined by three people who are at the heart of the decision to go to war. Former head of MI6, Richard Deerlove, Tony Blair's former communications director, Alistair Campbell, and former acting head of the CIA, Michael Morel.
看看那些捏造了把我们带入战争的情报的消息来源。伊拉克战争重塑了中东，并永远削弱了公众对政府和情报机构的信任，其后果至今仍在显现。此外，在一个解密俱乐部的独家节目中，我们邀请了三位处于开战决策核心的人物。前军情六处负责人理查德·迪尔洛夫、托尼·布莱尔的前通讯主任阿利斯泰尔·坎贝尔，以及前中情局代理局长迈克尔·莫尔.
So get the full story by listening to The Rest is Classified and subscribing to the Declassified Club wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因此，请收听《The Rest is Classified》，并在你获取播客的任何地方订阅“解密俱乐部”，以了解完整的故事。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。